AFTERNOON AND WELCOME TO OUR
JOINT HEARING ON HOMELESSNESS
FUNDING IN SUBCOMMITTEE FOREIGN
STATE ADMINISTRATION AND HOUSING
AND COMMUNITY DEVELOPMENT
COMMITTEE ONCE AGAIN THE BOTH OF
US MISSPOKE HE WORKS TODAY IN
ROOM FOR THE PANELISTS ON THE
AGENDA ARE PEERING REMOTELY
USING ONLINE TECHNOLOGY WE ARE
ACCEPTING PUBLIC COMMENT AT THE
END OF THIS HEARING BOTH IN THE
HEARING ROOM AND ON THE PHONE
THE PHONE NUMBER TO CONNECT IS
ON THE COMMITTEE WEBSITE. AND
SHOULD ALSO BE ON THE SCREEN IF
YOU'RE WATCHING OVER THE
INTERNET THE PHONE NUMBER IS
TOLL FREE. 877-692-8957 THE
PUBLIC ACCESS CODE IS. ONE THREE
ONE FIVE FOUR FOUR FOUR IF YOU
ENCOUNTER ANY PROBLEMS PLEASE
CONTACT THE ASSEMBLY BUDGET
COMMITTEE AT. 916-319-2099 AND A
STAFF MEMBER WILL ASSIST YOU WE
ENCOURAGE THE PUBLIC TO PROVIDE.
WRITTEN TESTIMONY BEFORE THE
HEARING PLEASE SEND YOUR WRITTEN
TESTIMONY TO BUDGETS OF FOUR AD
ASM DOT CA DOT GOP TODAY WE ARE
FOCUSING ON HOMEOWNERSHIP TO
BETTER UNDERSTAND WHAT POLICIES
WE CAN MAKE AT THE STATE LEVEL
TO HELP WITH HOMEOWNERSHIP
THROUGHOUT THE STATE WE KNOW
THAT THE MEDIUM HOME PRICES
THROUGHOUT THE STATE ARE VERY
HIGH AND THAT THE SUPPLY IS VERY
LOW MAKING IT MORE DIFFICULT TO
ENTER. THE MARKET THANK YOU. IN
L. A. COUNTY THE MEDIAN HOME
PRICE IS AT A RECORD HIGH OF.
EIGHT HUNDRED AND FIVE THOUSAND
DOLLARS. THERE IS A ARTICLE IN
THE LA TIMES- FROM THIS YEAR-
WHILE THE MEDIAN HOME PRICE AND
INTO A COUNTY FOR EXAMPLE RIGHT
NEXT DOOR. IS ABOUT SEVEN
HUNDRED AND FIFTY ONE THOUSAND
DOLLARS I HAVE A WHOLE LIST OF.
DATA THAT I LIKE TO SHARE AS WE
MOVE FORWARD MANY PEOPLE IN MY
COMMUNITY HAVE MOVED AWAY FROM
LOS ANGELES COUNTY. TO INTER
COUNTY OR TO EVEN SPRINGS AND
NEARBY AREAS BECAUSE
HOMEOWNERSHIP IS MORE
ATTAINABLE. OUTSIDE OF LOS
ANGELES HOWEVER. THAT MEANS THAT
THEY HAVE TO COMMUTE ABOUT TWO
HOURS EACH WAY. AND IN OUR QUEST
TO REDUCE CARBON EMISSIONS DUE
TO VEHICLES. THERE'S A REAL LIFE
EXAMPLE OF WHAT PEOPLE ARE GOING
THROUGH DOESN'T HELP REACH OUR
CLIMATE CHANGE GOALS. THIS
PRACTICE IS HAPPENING ACROSS THE
STATE AND IN NORTHERN CALIFORNIA
WITH MANY WORKERS LIVING IN THE
CENTRAL VALLEY. ARE COMMUTING
TWO BAY AREA CITIES THESE ARE
DECISIONS THAT ARE. CONSTITUENTS
HAVE TO MAKE EVERY DAY. BECOME
HOHNER HOMEOWNER'S EVEN IF IT
MEANS LIVING IN A SEPARATE
COUNTY FROM WHERE YOU WORK. AND
EVEN IF IT MEANS COMMUTING TWO
HOURS EACH WAY. THE LEGISLATURE
NEEDS TO DISCUSS HOW WE HELP
MORE CONSTITUENTS BECOME
HOMEOWNERS HOMEOWNERS. BUT NOT
JUST HOMEOWNERS TWO HOURS AWAY
FROM THEIR WORK BUT HOMEOWNERS.
IN THEIR OWN COMMUNITIES. WHAT
POLICIES COUNTY TAKE AS THE
LEGISLATURE TO MAKE THESE
CHANGES HAPPEN. WITH THAT I
WOULD LIKE TO HEAD OVER TO MY
CULTURE ASSEMBLY MEMBER WORKS.
FOR OPENING. REMARKS AND TO
INTRODUCE THE FIRST. THANK YOU
CHAIR ONE MOMENT OKAY THERE WE
GO THANK YOU CHAIR CARILLO- FOR
YOUR CONTINUED LEADERSHIP IN
THIS SPACE IN PARTNERSHIP AS WE
TRY TO TACKLE THESE REALLY
IMPORTANT ISSUES FACING. ALL OF
OUR COMMUNITIES HERE IN
CALIFORNIA. AND I WANT TO THANK
YOUR STAFF FOR THEIR WORK ON
THIS JOINT HEARING AS WELL. THIS
FALL A GROUP OF LEGISLATORS-
ALMOST THIRTY OF US- AT
DIFFERENT POINTS ATTENDED A-
HOUSING WORKING GROUP- TOUR
ACROSS THE STATE WE WERE
EVERYWHERE FROM. G. GO TO
CONCORD OAKLAND SALINAS INLAND
EMPIRE FRESNO- SAN DIEGO LOS
ANGELES ORANGE COUNTY- REALLY
TRYING TO GET A BETTER
UNDERSTANDING AND GRAPPLE WITH
WHAT ARE THE ISSUES FACING OUR
COMMUNITIES WHEN IT COMES TO
HOUSING AND HOMELESSNESS. AND AT
EVERY SINGLE STOP THE AYE THE
NOTION AROUND HOMEOWNERSHIP AND
THE- LACK THERE OF CAME UP. AND
THIS IS A PARTICULARLY YOU KNOW
VEXING ISSUE IN CALIFORNIA WE'VE
ALWAYS HAD A RELATIVELY LOW RATE
OF HOMEOWNERSHIP BUT- IT SAID I
THINK IT'S ONE OF THE WORST IN
THE COUNTRY AT THIS POINT I
THINK IT'S AROUND FIFTY FIVE
PERCENT. BUT IT'S PARTICULARLY
CHALLENGING FOR COMMUNITIES OF
COLOR. AND IN AMERICA THIS IS
HOW WE BUILD WEALTH IT'S HOW WE
BUILD GENERATIONAL WEALTH IS
THROUGH HOMEOWNERSHIP
OPPORTUNITIES. AND FOR BRENDA
BLACK COMMUNITIES RIGHT NOW FOR
MANY OF THEM. IT IS SIMPLY NOT
ATTAINABLE- AND SO THERE'S A
REAL EQUITY ISSUES HERE THAT WE
NEED TO EXPLORE AND THINKING
THROUGH HOW WE ALL CAN. HELP
SOLVE THE PROBLEM- IS I THINK
THE CHALLENGE AND OPPORTUNITY
PRESENTED IN FRONT OF US HERE-
IT'S WHY I'M EXCITED TO
INTRODUCE OUR FIRST WITNESS AND
THRILLED THAT SOME OF OUR
COLLEAGUES HAVE JOINED FOR THE
HEARING AS WELL I KNOW THEY HAVE
IT CONTINUE COMMITMENTS WELL TO
SOLVING THIS PROBLEM- AND OUR
FIRST. GUEST HERE WILL BE STEVEN
MANDAEAN WHO IS THE ASSISTANT
DIRECTOR OF OTHERING AND
BELONGING INSTITUTE STEVEN
YOU'LL HAVE A COUPLE. ALLOWED
THE OVERVIEW OF THE HOUSING
MARKET IN CALIFORNIA AND ALSO
APPRECIATE YOUR- ATTENTION TO
THE EQUITY ISSUES THAT. ARE
FACING OUR COMMUNITIES. THANK
YOU SHOWS SO I ASSUME I'M
STARTING OUT THANK YOU YEP THANK
YOU- I'M GONNA OPEN UP MY SLIDE
DECK AND HOPEFULLY THIS WILL
SHARE I'VE BEEN ASKED TO.
PRESENT ON THE DISPARITIES IN
RACIAL HOMEOWNERSHIP RATES AND
THEN. OUTLINED SOME POLICIES
THAT ARE CAPABLE. OF PRODUCING
THOSE DISPARITIES SOME TO DO
THAT AND I I'VE BEEN TOLD I HAVE
TWELVE MINUTES ON THIS GET.
STARTED HERE. SO THIS IS A CHART
THAT WAS CREATED BY THE NATIONAL
COMMUNITY REINVESTMENT COALITION
I'M GOING TO BREAK THIS DOWN.
THAT IS CENTRALLY SHOWS
DISAGGREGATED LEVELS OF
HOMEOWNERSHIP ACROSS THE UNITED
STATES BUT REYES. WHAT THE BASIC
PATTERN SHOWS IS THAT AFTER THE
GREAT DEPRESSION. ERIC CANS BY
AND LARGE MOST AMERICANS DID NOT
OWN THEIR OWN HOME AND MANY
AMERICANS HAVE BEEN DISPOSSESSED
FROM HOMEOWNERSHIP- AS A RESULT
OF THE GREAT DEPRESSION AND SO
YOU CAN SEE THE VERY LOW LEVELS
OF HOME OWNERSHIP BUT IN THE
POST WAR PERIOD HOMEOWNERSHIP
SURGED AND SURGED WITH BOMBS AND
IT WITH FITS AND STARTS IN THE
IN THE TWENTY FIRST CENTURY AS
WELL. BUT HERE'S WHAT I WANT TO
FOCUS IN ON THIS THIS COMES FROM
THE ST LOUIS FED IT SHOWS THE
QUEUE FOR TWENTY TWENTY ONE
HOMEOWNERSHIP RATES BY RACE
ACROSS UNITED STATES ABOUT 66%
ROUNDING UP HERE 266% OF ALL
AMERICANS OWN THEIR OWN HOME-
BUT WHEN YOU DISAGGREGATE BY
RACE YOU SEE HUGE DISPARITIES.
SO ABOUT 74% OF WHITE AMERICANS
ON THEIR OWN HOME BUT ONLY 44%
OF BLACK AMERICANS WITH 48% OF
LATINOS AND 61% OF ASIANS.
HERE'S THE INTERESTING AND
DISTURBING FACT. THIS DISPARITY%
HAS ACTUALLY GOTTEN WORSE OVER
TIME NOT BETTER. SO IF YOU LOOK
AT THE RATE OF HOMEOWNERSHIP. IN
NINETEEN SEVENTY WHICH IS WHEN
THE FEDERAL FAIR HOUSING ACT
GOES INTO EFFECT. YOU'LL SEE THE
TOTAL AMOUNT OF HOMEOWNERSHIP IN
NINETEEN SEVENTY IN THE COUNTRY
. THEN TODAY. WHITE
HOMEOWNERSHIP THOUGH 66% AND
BLACK HOMEOWNERSHIP IS FORTY TWO
PERCENT. IN TWENTY TWENTY. BOB
HUGHES IN THE QUEUE FOR DATA YOU
SEE THE BLACK HOME OWNERSHIP HAS
INCREASED TWO PERCENTAGE POINTS
ABSOLUTE INCREASE OVER THAT
FIFTY YEAR PERIOD. BUT HERE'S
THE PROBLEM THE BLACK WHITE
DISPARITY HAS ACTUALLY RISEN
FROM 24% TO THIRTY PERCENT. YOU
KNOW BECAUSE OF THE DESPITE THE
BLACK WHITE DISPARITY. IS THE
WORST IT HAS EVER BEEN LOOKING
AT THE TEN YEAR SNAPSHOT SINCE
NINETEEN FORTY. IT'S 30% IS THE
LARGEST GAP THE REASON IS
BECAUSE- BLACK HOME OWNERSHIP
HAS NOT ONLY. NOT INCREASED VERY
FAST BUT WHITE HOMEOWNERSHIP HAS
INCREASED REMARKABLY SINCE THE
POST WORLD WAR TWO. NOW I HAVE
THAT I HAVE THE DATA UP FOR
CALIFORNIA WHICH YOU JUST
MENTIONED THE CALIFORNIA HAS A
MUCH LOWER RATE OF HOMEOWNERSHIP
AND INDEED IT DOES. I IN FACT
THESE FINDINGS ARE THINK ARE IN
MANY WAYS EVEN MORE DISTURBING.
SO WE SAW THAT NATIONALLY BLACK
HOMEOWNERSHIP IS 44% IN
CALIFORNIA THAT'S 36% THE LATEST
DATA I COULD GET IS FROM THE ACS
HERE. THE TWENTY TWENTY-
FEDERER'S SERVE DATA IS ACTUALLY
AN ESTIMATE SO. I DIDN'T WANT TO
SHARE WITH YOU AN ESTIMATE HAS
TO BE CLEANED UP SO THE TWENTY
NINETEEN IS THE MOST RECENT DATA
FOR ITS 36% THE DISPARITY.
ALMOST AS LARGE AS THE NATIONAL
DISPARITY THE BLACK WHITE
DISPARITY TONY SEVEN PERCENT.
BUT YOU'LL SEE. THAT THE RATE
THE ABSOLUTE RATE IS MUCH LOWER.
CLOSER TO A THIRD SO THIS IS
THIS IS QUITE DISTURBING. BOB
THERE ARE MANY ASPECTS OF
HOUSING THAT IS RACIALIZED I
COULD TALK ABOUT DISPARITIES IN
HOME VALUES HOME VALUE
APPRECIATION HOME EQUITY IN THE
FOR WEALTH. I COULD HAVE SEVERAL
SLIDES MY APPENDIX ON THE RACIAL
WEALTH GAP IF YOU'RE CURIOUS
ABOUT THAT. I COULD TALK ABOUT
DISPARITIES IN APPRAISALS
DISPARITIES IN PROPERTY TAX
ASSESSMENTS AND DELINQUENCIES
CREDITS EDIT LOW DIAL
SEGREGATION DISCRIMINATION AND
STEERING AND MUCH MORE. BUT I
WAS ASKED SPECIFICALLY TO TALK
ABOUT HOMEOWNERSHIP. THERE ARE A
BROAD RANGE OF ORGANIZATIONS
THAT HAVE CALLED UPON GOVERNMENT
BOTH FEDERAL STATE GOVERNMENTS.
AND LOCAL GOVERNMENTS TO SUPPORT
IN THE FINANCIAL INDUSTRY TO
SUPPORT BLACK HOMEOWNERSHIP. SO
GIVE YOU A FEW EXAMPLES AND I'LL
GIVE YOU SOME EXAMPLE POLICIES.
THE URBAN INSTITUTE IN THE
NATIONAL FAIR HOUSING ALLIANCE
HAVE MADE IT THE CENTERPIECE OF
THEIR KEYS TO UNLOCK DREAMS
INITIATIVE. THEY PROPOSED- THE
DOWN PAYMENT ASSISTANCE WITH THE
GOAL OF THREE MILLION NEW BLACK
HOMEOWNERS BY TWENTY THIRTY. THE
NATIONAL COALITION THE COMMUNITY
REINVESTMENT COALITION SEVEN
EVEN MORE AGGRESSIVE GOAL. OF
RAISING THAT FORTY FOUR
PERCENTAGE POINTS. A BLACK
HOMEOWNERSHIP RATE 260% BY
TWENTY FORTY. SEVERAL OF
PRESIDENTIAL CANDIDATES LIKE
PEOPLE TO CHURCH IN THE DOUGLAS
PLAN HAVE ARGUED FOR
HOMEOWNERSHIP FUND THAT WOULD
TARGET. FAMILIES RESIDING IN
FORMALLY REDLINED NEIGHBORHOODS
ELIZABETH WARREN HAD A SIMILAR
INITIATIVE. HOWEVER IF YOU READ
THE SCHOLARSHIP NOT EVERYONE IS
ENTIRELY ENTHUSIASTIC ABOUT
BLACK HOMEOWNERSHIP OF EMORY
PROFESSOR AND TAX LAW EXPERT
DOROTHY BROWN WHO'S WRITTEN A
PHENOMENAL BOOK THE WHITENESS OF
WEALTH. CLICK THAT HOMEOWNERSHIP
IN AMERICA IS A BAD DEAL FOR
MOST BLACK AMERICANS SHE
ULTIMATELY CONCLUDES THAT BOB WE
SHOULD PROMOTE BLACK
HOMEOWNERSHIP BUT SHE SAYS BUT
THERE ARE A NUMBER OF CABBIE
OUGHT TO THAT SPECIFICALLY AGAIN
BLACK HOMEOWNERS ENJOY LESS.
EQUITY APPRECIATION AND I THINK
OUR BIGGEST CONCERN IS THE TO
MAXIMIZE EQUITY BLACK HOMEOWNERS
PROBABLY HAVE TO PURCHASE HOMES
IN WHITE NEIGHBORHOODS SO.
THERE'S SOME COMMITTEE TRADE
OFFS THERE ON SHE HAS A
PHENOMENAL BOOK ON DISPARITIES
IN THE TAX CODE BUT LOOK AT-
SOME OF THE IMPLICATIONS OF
HOMEOWNERSHIP IN THAT REGARD AS
WELL. BOB CAN ALSO OCCUR IN
OTHER SCHOLARS ECONOMISTS LIKE
SANDY DIRTY POINT OUT EVEN IF
DISPARITIES IN HOMEOWNERSHIP
RATES WERE SIGNIFICANTLY
REDUCED. DISPARITIES IN HOME
EQUITY MEAN THAT THE RACIAL
WEALTH GAP WOULD STILL REMAIN
OUTSTANDINGLY LARGE. OKAY ONE
MORE COPY UP BEFORE SURE SOME
POLICIES. SPECIFIC POLICIES ONE
OF THE PROBLEMS IS THAT THERE IS
A BIG DIFFERENCE IN THE
LITERATURE BETWEEN WHAT YOU
MIGHT CALL RACE TARGETED
POLICIES VERSUS THOSE THAT ARE
RACE CONSCIOUS. TOOK THE MOST
DIRECT ROUTE TO PROMOTING BLACK
OR MINORITY HOMEOWNERSHIP WOULD
BE TARGETED POLICIES TO BLACK
FAMILIES THESE ARE POLICIES THAT
ADDRESS STRUCTURAL RACISM BY
TARGETING PEOPLE ON THE BASIS OF
THEIR RACE AND PROVIDING
BENEFITS ARE EXTENDING
PROTECTIONS ON THAT BASIS.
CONTRACT RACE CONSCIOUS POLICIES
ARE THOSE THAT ARE DESIGNED FOR
RACIAL PURPOSE BUT ARE USUALLY
RACE NEUTRAL EITHER UNIVERSALIST
TECH OR CLASS BASED IN DESIGNER
FORM. THE REASON THAT MANY OF
THESE POLICIES ARE RACE
CONSCIOUS INSTEAD OF RACE
TARGETED BECAUSE FEDERAL LAW AND
SOME PARTS OF STATE LAW MEETIC
MAKE IT EXTREMELY DIFFICULT TO
ADOPT REYES TARGETED POLICIES AS
A RESULT UNIVERSALIST POLICIES
OR PROXIES FOR RACE ARE MORE
COMMON. PROPOSITION TWO OH TWO
NINE BY THE WAY DOES NOT
PROHIBIT THE STATE'S AGING AND
IN RACE CAR OR. EVEN RACE
TARGETED. A HOUSE IMPULSE.
PROPOSITION TWO ONE NIGHT ONLY A
TO A- CONTRACT AT. JUST WANTED
TO NOTE THAT. SO WHAT ARE THE
POLICIES TO. PROMOTE
HOMEOWNERSHIP AND REDUCE THE
RACIAL DISPARITIES WELL ONE
DISCOUNTED INTEREST RATES ON
MORTGAGES AND MORTGAGES
ASSISTANCE DOWN PAYMENT
ASSISTANCE CLOSING COST
INSURANCE ASSISTANT PROPERTY TAX
ABATEMENTS AND RELIEF. REPAIRS
UPKEEP AND MAINTENANCE
ASSISTANCE LAND GRANTS
INVESTMENTS IN BLACK OWNED
FINANCIAL INSTITUTIONS THE IDEA
BEING THAT IF THEY HAVE MORE
CAPITAL THEY CAN OFFER. MORE
LENDING. BOB A GOOD EXAMPLE OF
THEM TO GO THROUGH FOR SPECIFICS
AND I'LL BE DONE. SO IN THE BOOK
MOVING TO INTEGRATION RICHARD
SANDERS CO AUTHORS RICHARD
CENTER. TEACHES IN THE UC SYSTEM
. HAVE DEVISED A PLAN. FOR
PROMOTING RACIAL INTEGRATION IN
A METRIC MAJOR METROPOLITAN
AREA. THE COST OF THE PROPOSAL
TWO HUNDRED EIGHTY FIVE MILLION
BUT THE ONE THING I WANT TO
POINT OUT FOR YOU HERE. THEY
ESTIMATE THAT IT ONE PERCENTAGE
POINT INTEREST RATE SUBSIDY ON
THE FIRST A HUNDRED THOUSAND
DOLLARS OF A MORTGAGE LOAN WOULD
COST ONLY FORTY FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS. DOLLARS WHAT HELPING
MORE THAN TEN THOUSAND BORROWERS
POTENTIALLY FIND HOMES. SO WHILE
IT'S VERY EXPENSIVE TO PROVIDES
UP HOMES AND SUBSIDIES FOR
HOMES. INTEREST RATE. SUBSIDIES
ARE MUCH LESS EXPENSIVE. FOR
EXAMPLES NUMBER ONE OTHER RACE
CONSCIOUS HOMEOWNERSHIP PROGRAM
IS THE CLEVELAND RACIAL
INTEGRATION INITIATIVE. THIS IS
AN OBSCURE PROGRAM FOR THE
NINETEEN EIGHTIES THE PROVIDED
LOW INTEREST MORTGAGE FUNDS FOR
BLACK AND WHITE HOMEBUYERS- IT
WAS. ADMINISTERED FOR SHORT TIME
BY THE OHIO HOUSING FINANCE
AGENCY AND TARGET FEW CLEVELAND
SUBURBS. AND IT ALL IT MADE MORE
THAN THREE MILLION LOANS IN
NINETEEN EIGHTY FIVE. TO A
NUMBER OF WHITE AND BLACK
MORTGAGE YOURS. THE CHECK THE
PROGRAM WAS CHALLENGED ON LEGAL
GROUNDS THAT SURVIVED BUT IT WAS
ULTIMATELY DISCONTINUED A FEW
YEARS LATER. ANOTHER EXAMPLE OF
THE RACE CONSCIOUS HOMEOWNERSHIP
PLAN IS A PROGRAM IS THE
EVANSTON ILLINOIS REPARATIONS
PROGRAM. THIS IS A SUBURB
OUTSIDE OF CHICAGO THE CREATED A
QUOTABLE REPARATIONS FUND IN
TWENTY NINETEEN. ABOUT SHOULD
JUST CARRY OUT THAT A LOT OF
PEOPLE CRITICIZED THE CITY FOR
USING THE TERM REPARATIONS SO
I'M JUST BORROWING WHAT THEIR
APPELLATION RATHER THAN. HOW
SCHOLARS PREFER TO REFER TO
THIS.NONETHELESS THEY'VE
COLLECTED A TEN MILLION DOLLARS
AND HOUSING ASSISTANCE THERE GET
DISBURSING THROUGH SMALL GRANTS.
ELIGIBILITY IS BASED ON EITHER
PROVING THAT YOUR ANCESTOR WAS A
RESIDENT ABOUT IT IN EVANSTON
BETWEEN NINETEEN NINETEEN TO
NINETEEN SIXTY NINE. OR COULD
HAVE BEEN COUNTED HOUSING
DISCRIMINATION BECAUSE OF CITY
POLICIES AFTER NINETEEN SIXTY
NINE. THE GRANTS DO NOT GO TO
INDIVIDUAL HOME SEEKERS TO GO TO
BANKS OR BUSINESSES WHO THEN-
WHO THAT AND- PROVIDE LOANS TO.
HOME SEEKERS AND THIS WAS DONE
TO AVOID. INCOME TAX. LIABILITY
FOR HOME SEEKERS. AND GRANTS ARE
TO USE FOR HOMER MORE ASSISTANCE
OR DOWN. THERE TO PROGRAMS OF
MASSIVE. THREE BY THE WAY I
SHOULD JUST CARRY OUT THAT
THERE'S CAL AT EIGHT. IN TWENTY
TWENTY TWENTY ONE LAUNCHED A
BLACK HOMEOWNERSHIP INITIATIVE
BUT IT'S MORE OF A CAMPAIGN. THE
DETAILS ARE UNCLEAR TO ME- BUT
IT DOES HAVE SOME ELEMENTS
APPEAR TO HAVE SOME ELEMENTS
THERE SIMILAR TO THESE OTHER TWO
PROGRAMS I WOULD IMAGINE. BUT
THE CITY BOSTON IN TWENTY TWENTY
ADOPTED. THIS PROGRAM THE FIRST
GENERATION HOMEBUYER PROGRAM TO
PROVIDES. GRANTS OF FIVE
THOUSAND DOLLARS TO NEW HOME
BUYERS. ELIGIBILITY IS BASED ON
INCOME- NOT ON RACE. HOWEVER OUT
OF THE HUNDRED FIFTY HOME BUYERS
THAT ARE CURRENTLY IN THE
PROGRAM. 73% ARE BLACK AND 18%
ARE LATINO- THE SECOND PROGRAM A
MENTION IS THE ONE PLUS BOSTON
PROGRAM THIS IS ANOTHER FIRST
TIME HOME BUYER SUBSIDY OF THE
CITY OF BOSTON. WITH THE GOAL OF
CREATING A THOUSAND NEW
HOMEOWNERS BY THE END OF TWENTY
TWENTY THREE IT OFFERS FIXED THE
LOWEST FIXED INTEREST RATES ON A
THIRTY YEAR MORTGAGE. SO IT IT.
LOWERS THE INTEREST RATE BY
EITHER A POINT OR A FULL POINT
HALF. BITES OTHER CLOSING COSTS
ASSISTANCE AND OTHER EVEN DOWN
PAYMENT ASSISTANCE. ELIGIBILITY
IS BASED ON INCOME AS WELL AND
RESIDING IN THE CITY LIMITS. BOB
I'LL JUST DIRECT YOUR ATTENTION
THIS PROJECT IS LAUNCHING
TOMORROW. THIS IS CALLED THE
STRUCTURAL RACISM REMEDIES
PROJECT THIS IS A PROJECT THAT
WE'VE BEEN INCUBATING FOR YEAR
AND A HALF. AND THERE ARE
SPECIFIC POLICIES DRAWN FROM
ALMOST SEVENTY SCHOLARLY AND
ADVOCACY ORGANIZATION DOCUMENTS.
ON HOUSING THAT ARE BOTH RATES
TARGETED IN RACE CONSCIOUS. AND
IT HAS ABOUT FORTY OR FIFTY
RECOMMENDED POLICIES ALONG THE
LINES OF JUST MENTIONED. HAPPY
TO DISCUSS ANY OF THEM IN MORE
DETAIL THIS IS THE U. R. L. IT'S
GOING TO BE ON OUR WEBSITE
TOMORROW BUT THIS IS A PREVIEW
FOR YOU HERE. AND THANK YOU FOR
GIVE ME AN OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK
ABOUT THIS IMPORTANT TOPIC HAPPY
TO ANSWER ANY OTHER QUESTIONS
YOU MAY HAVE. THANK YOU SO MUCH
MISTER. THE NAVY AND I WANT TO
GO BACK TO SOMETHING THAT YOU
SAID THAT REALLY STRUCK A CHORD
AND THEN I'LL PASS IT BACK TO
OUR CO CHAIR AND- MEMBERS OF THE
DIETS. CAN YOU PLEASE ELABORATE
ON WHAT YOU SAID REGARDING PROP
TWO OH NINE. AND HOUSING AS IT
RELATES TO- DIVERSITY AND EQUITY
. YES SO PROPOSITION TWO OH NINE
IS THIS NOTORIOUS LOG THAT WAS
AT NINETEEN NINETY SIX OR NINETY
SEVEN BALLOT INITIATIVE. THAT
SENSUALLY CREATES A BARRIER TO
EXPLICIT CONSIDERATION OF RACE
IN PUBLIC POLICY IN A NUMBER OF
WAYS HOWEVER. PROPOSITION TWO OH
NINE BY ITS OWN TERMS ONLY
APPLIES TO CONTRACTING
EMPLOYMENT. AND EDUCATION. SO
FOR EXAMPLE IT MEANS THAT THE UC
SYSTEM'S YOU SEE UNIVERSITIES
AND COLLEGES AND COMMUNITY
COLLEGES IN CALIFORNIA. CANNOT
CONSIDERATION SPLIT THAT WE AS A
FACTORED ADMISSIONS. OB OR
PUBLIC MUNICIPALITIES REPUBLIC
AGENCIES CITIES AND PUBLIC
AGENCIES CAN'T CONSIDER RACE IN
CONTRACTING OR HIGHER. WERE
MAKING EMPLOYMENT DECISIONS IT
DOES NOT APPLY TO HOUSING
TRANSPORTATION INFRASTRUCTURE
STUFF LIKE THAT IT ONLY APPLIES
TO CONTRACTING EMPLOYMENT AND
EDUCATION HOWEVER. FORTUNATELY
THE FEDERAL CONSTITUTION HAS
BEEN INTERPRETED I DON'T AGREE
WITH THAT INTERPRETATION BUT
THIS IS THE PREVAILING
INTERPRETATION THE SUPREME
COURT. IS TO ESSENTIALLY. MAKE
ALL CLASS RACIAL
CLASSIFICATIONS. SUBJECT TO
WHAT'S CALLED STRICT SCRUTINY
REVIEW. WHICH MEANS THAT ANY
TIME THE STATE GOVERNMENT OR
LOCAL GOVERNMENT OR THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT. USES RACE AS AN
EXPLICIT. INDIVIDUAL LEVEL
CONSIDERATION OF POLICY MAKING
FEDERAL COURTS WILL
PRESUMPTIVELY. REGARD THAT IS
UNCONSTITUTIONAL UNLESS IT
PASSES WHAT'S CALLED STRICT
SCRUTINY REVIEW MEETING THAT HAS
TO BE SUPPORTED BY. A COMPELLING
GOVERNMENT INTEREST. A NARROWLY
TAILORED TO SERVE THAT INTEREST
. SO HOPEFULLY I ANSWERED THE
QUESTION ABOUT PROP TWO OH NINE
IT DOES NOT APPLY TO HOUSING.
THE THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR THAT
APPRECIATED- APPRECIATE THE
BACKGROUND HERE- HE TALKED TO A
NUMBER OF IDEAS OF HOW WE CAN
SORT OF HELP SOLVE THIS PROBLEM
IF YOU COULD WAVE A MAGIC WAND
WHAT YOU THINK IS THE MOST
IMPORTANT THING WE CAN DO TO
INCREASE HOMEOWNERSHIP FOR BROWN
TO BLACK COMMUNITIES. WELL IT'S
HARD FOR ME TO PICK AND CHOOSE
BETWEEN THOSE LESS BUT IF THERE
WAS ONE SILVER BULLET. AND THIS
IS NOT GOING TO BE- IT'S NOT
ACTUALLY HOMEOWNERSHIP POLICY
WOULD ACTUALLY BE A REPARATIONS
POLICY. AND I DON'T THINK IT'S
SOMETHING THE STATE COULD DO.
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT HAVE TO
REPARATIONS. BUT THE ONE THING
THAT CAN MAKE THE BIGGEST
DIFFERENCE IN TERMS OF REDUCING
THE RACIAL WEALTH GAP. IT WOULD
BE A FEDERALREPARATIONS POLICY.
BECAUSE SHE PUTTING SIGNIFICANT
WEALTH INTO UP. INTO BLACK
FAMILIES ACROSS THE STATE AND
THEREFORE IT WOULD MAKE IT MUCH
EASIER FOR THEM TO AFFORD
HOMEOWNERSHIP. BEYOND FEDERAL
REPARATIONS POLICY WHICH ISN'T
SOMETHING I REALIZE YOU HAVE THE
CAPACITY TO DO. I THINK THESE
POLICIES THAT I MENTIONED TERMS
OF INTEREST RATE SUBSIDIES DOWN
PAYMENT ASSISTANCE. CLOSING COST
ASSISTANCE THOSE SORTS OF
SUBSIDIES. ACTUALLY HAVE
SIGNIFICANT PROMISE. THE PROBLEM
IS YOU CAN'T DO IT IN INDIVIDUAL
LEVEL. BUT YOU CAN'T DO IT IN
USING CERTAIN PROXIES LIKE
INCOME. WEALTH OR UP. THE RACE
THE RACIAL COMPOSITION OF THE
NEIGHBORHOOD. SO I THINK ALL OF
THOSE HAVE GREAT PROMISE. THANK
YOU APPRECIATED AND WILL BRING
ABOUT HER TO THE DAIS FOR. ANY
OF OUR COLLEAGUES HERE WHO OF
OTHER FOLLOW UP QUESTIONS MISS
CLARK SILVA. THANK YOU GREAT
INFORMATION. ONE OF THE THINGS
IS THAT YOU MENTIONED OF COURSE-
BLACK INDIVIDUALS ARE LAGGING
BEHIND LATINOS BUT I'M WONDERING
ABOUT THE DATA. IN CALIFORNIA IN
THE SENSE THAT- LATINO-
INDIVIDUALS ARE FAR MORE OF
THEM- A LARGER POPULATION IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA SO. WHAT
THOSE NUMBERS ACTUALLY LOOK
DIFFERENT WHEN YOU COMPARE- FOR
THE NUMBER OF POPULATION IN EACH
OF THOSE SUBGROUPS. MEANING THAT
IT WILL IT COULD IT LOOKED TO ME
AS- LATINOS ARE REALLY ACTUALLY
LAGGING BEHIND- OUR BLACK
BROTHERS AND SISTERS BECAUSE OF
. ALMOST TRIPLE THE POPULATION.
WELL LET ME BE CLEAR IMAGES
SHOWED THIS SLIDE AGAIN THIS IS
HOMEOWNERSHIP IN CALIFORNIA BY
RACE THIS IS- THIS IS THESE ARE
RATES MEANING THAT THEY ARE
BASED ON THE PERCENTAGE OF EACH
RACIAL GROUP ALSO ADAM SO WHAT
IT SHOWS HERE IS THAT IN
CALIFORNIA I THINK AS MEMBER
WICKS MENTIONED BEFORE THE TOTAL
RATE OF HOMEOWNERSHIP IN
CALIFORNIA'S FIFTY FIVE PERCENT.
THE WHITE RATE OF HOMEOWNERSHIP
63% MEANING 63% OF WHITE
HOUSEHOLDS OWN THEIR OWN HOME IN
CALIFORNIA AND THAT RATE IS ONLY
44% FOR LATINOS IN CALIFORNIA
MEANING THAT IT'S A SIGNIFICANT
DISPARITY RIGHT IT'S ALMOST
TWENTY POINTS BEHIND WHITE
HOMEOWNERSHIP. NO I GET THAT
PART BUT THEY'RE JUST THEY'RE
THEY'RE OVER 50% OF THE
POPULATION. RIGHT ABSOLUTE
NUMBERS THIS IS IT THIS MEANS
THAT IT'S A HUGE PERCENTAGE
DISPARITY IN ABSOLUTE TERMS IT'S
YES YOU'RE RIGHT IT'S PROBABLY A
MUCH LARGER ABSOLUTE DISPARITY
AND WHY DIDN'T WE HAVE A NUMBER
WHERE THEY JUST NOT TRACKING
NUMBERS IN THE FORTIES FIFTIES
AND SIXTIES FOR LATINOS AND
ASIANS. ALL THAT THIS IS THIS IS
INCREDIBLY HARD TO GET TOGETHER
HAVE A WHOLE TEAM OF RESEARCH
SUPPORT HELP ME GET THIS. BOB
THE DATA SOURCE HERE IS AYE
POEMS- BEFORE TWO THOUSAND AND
ITS- DEFENSE SO THE ANSWER YOUR
QUESTION IS BASICALLY BUT YES
FEDERAL THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT.
DID NOT ACTUALLY DISAGGREGATE.
DATA INTELLECT LATINO UNTIL
NINETEEN EIGHTY AND ASIAN. TILL
NINETEEN EIGHTY IT'S IT WAS IT'S
VERY HARD TO GET FEDERAL DATA.
DISAGGREGATED BY RACE INTO A
LATINO AND ASIAN BEFORE NINETEEN
EIGHTY IT ESSENTIALLY DOESN'T
EXIST UNFORTUNATELY. THANK YOU
THOUGH THE SECRETARY WELL DONE I
APPRECIATE IT. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU OTHER QUESTIONS FROM OUR
COLLEAGUES. OKAY I WILL TURN IT
BACK OVER TO OUR CULTURE TO
INTRODUCE THE SECOND PANEL.
THANK YOU. OUR SECOND PANEL IS
ON A STATE OWNERSHIP PROGRAMS
AND INCLUDES MR FROM SERVICE
MISTER MARTI LEGISLATIVE
DIRECTOR AND PETER CALDWELL OR
THEY ON THE LINE. THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR CAL HFA. YES YES MY
NAME IS- FROM SAYS MARTY. CAN WE
HIRE HIS VOLUME PLEASE. HELLO
CAN YOU CAN YOU HEAR ME. YOU MAY
NEED TO SPEAK CLOSER INTO YOUR
MICROPHONE THE SOUND A LITTLE
FAR AWAY. HELLO CAN YOU HEAR ME
NOW YES MUCH BETTER. OKAY SHARES
WICKS AND COVER YOU KNOW AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE. FELLOW
PANELIST MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC.
MY NAME IS FRANCES MARTINEZ THE
DIRECTOR OF LEGISLATION AND
POLICY FOR THE CALIFORNIA
HOUSING FINANCE AGENCY. COLLEGE
AFFECT. AND I'M JOINED TODAY BY
ALAN MARTIN DIRECTOR OF BUSINESS
DEVELOPMENT AND STAKEHOLDER
RELATIONS AND CHERYL HANKS. THE
HOUSING FINANCE CHIEF IN A
SINGLE FAMILY DIVISION. THANK
YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK
BEFORE YOU TODAY I'LL BE
PROVIDING SOME THOUGHTS ON THE
HOMEOWNERSHIP LANDSCAPE CULTURE
FACE ROLE. AND ALSO ON HOW TO
ADDRESS THE CONTINUING
HOMEOWNERSHIP JOHN. TOOK OUT.
RATE OF A HAS DROPPED. SINCE TWO
THOUSAND EIGHT GRAVEN AND AS JOE
WICKS ON THE PREVIOUS. ROUGHLY
WE HAVE ONE OF THE LOWEST
HOMEOWNERSHIP RATES IN THE-
NATION THAT IS IN FACT THE THIRD
LOWEST JUST BEHIND. NEW YORK IN
THE SAME AND ACCESS TO
HOMEOWNERSHIP PARTICULARLY FOR
LOW AND MODERATE INCOME FAMILIES
IS SEVERELY CHALLENGED BY A
RECORD. HIGH HOME PRICES AS
REFERENCED BY CHECK OUT TO YOU.
DRIVEN BY HIGH DEMAND AND LOW
SUPPLY THIS PUSHES EVEN MORE
HOUSEHOLD STORES THE RENTAL
MARKET WHICH IS SIMILARLY
CONSTRAINED. BY LOW SUPPLY AND
HIGH PRICES. CHOKING TWENTY
TWENTY TWO THE ONGOING SUPPLY
DEMAND IMBALANCE IS EXPECTED TO
CONTINUE TO PUT UPWARD PRESSURE
ON HOME PRICES. WHICH MAY
PARTIALLY BE. OFFSET BY RISING
INTEREST RATES. SO HOW DOES JEFF
. FITTED THE PICTURE. TELOGEN
PHASE ROLE IN THE HOMEOWNERSHIP
SPACE IS TO. WE HAVE. FIRST TIME
HOME BUYER CULTIVATED A LARGE
PROVIDER DUMPING ASSISTANCE THE
STATE. AND THEN SECOND WE
EXISTING BUYERS THROUGH.
ASSISTANCE AND HOW TO COUNSELING
. AND SO DOES THE FIRST THING
BUYER WORK. HOW DO YOU THINK
WORKS WITH THE NOW OF LENDERS
THAT WORKED DIRECTLY WITH
HOMEBUYER. AND HE'S QUALIFIED
FOR THE HOME BUYER WE THE FIRST
MORTGAGE ALL WITH THE PAYMENTS.
IN THE FORM OF A SUPPORT AND ALL
. FIRST RESIDENTIAL ON THE SICK
MARKET. AND TOUCH BASE MORE
DEPENDS ON THE ISSUE FEDERAL
CONF. LOANS TO ENSURE ACCESS TO
AND MULTI TRILLION SECONDARY
MARKET. AND AVOID BALANCE SHEET
RISK. CUT TO BE ABLE TO ACCESS
THE PRIVATE CAPITAL MARKETS
THANKS TO THE WAY WE ARE BUILT
WITHIN A TWENTY THIS SELF
SUPPORTING. AS HONEST SELF
SUPPORTING ENTITY WITH A
SEPARATE CREDIT RATING. THE
FIRST MORTGAGE BALL ARE BETWEEN
TWO ONE FOUR BILLION ANNUALLY
DEPENDING ON WHEN WE ARE IN THE
REAL ESTATE MARKET. MARKET CYCLE
AND THESE VOLUMES AND THAT THESE
VOLUMES WE ARE ABLE TO HELP
BETWEEN SIX THOUSAND AND THIRTY
THOUSAND HOUSEHOLDS A YEAR AGAIN
DEPENDING ON WHAT WE ARE IN THE-
REAL STATE MARKET CYCLE AND
THAT DOESN'T ROBUST TEN PERCENT.
OF THE MARKET SHARE STAKEHOLDERS
PLAN. AND WE DO THAT I DID.
ABOUT A HIGH BETWEEN A HUNDRED
AND TWO HUNDRED MILLION. EVERY
YEAR CAN STATE SUPPORTIVE STATE
SUPPORTED DOWN PAYMENT
ASSISTANCE. SO THAT MEANS THAT
WE'RE LEVERAGING TWENTY PRIVATE
DOLLARS FOR EVERY DOLLAR IN
STATE. I WANT TO EMPHASIZE THE
FUNDAMENTAL DRIVER OF WHAT WE DO
A COLLEGE OF FATE IS REDRESSING
THE PERSISTENT RACIAL WEALTH GAP
AND THE LEGACY OF GOVERNMENT
SUCH SANCTIONS SYSTEMIC RACIAL
SEGREGATION AND HOPPING AND
EXPLAINED. IN DETAIL BY. THE
PREVIOUS FINALIST WE ARE PROUD
THAT SEVEN OUT OF TEN HOUSEHOLDS
WE SERVE OUR FROM COMMUNITIES OF
COLOR 53% OF OUR BORROWERS A
LATINO. HI AND 8% ARE BLACK. WE
ESTIMATE THAT OUR BORROWERS.
HOMES. I PRESENTING OVER A
HUNDRED SIX THOUSAND IN ADDITION
YOU KNOW EQUITY FOR EACH OF
THOSE HOUSEHOLDS WITH HELPED. SO
WE KNOW THAT GETTING HOME BUYERS
INTO THEIR FIRST HOMES WILL NOT
WILL NOT SOLVE THE PROBLEM IF
HOME OWNERSHIP RATES IN
VULNERABLE COMMUNITIES CONTINUE
TO ERODE. THAT IS WHY CALAFATE
PROVIDES RESOURCES TO HOMEBUYER
EDUCATION AND COUNSELING AND WE
EXERCISED SUSTAINABLE
HOMEOWNERSHIP AS A MAJOR LESSON
OF THE TWO THOUSAND AND A
CRISIS. AND WE ALSO JUST
LAUNCHED A NEW MORTGAGE RELIEF
PROGRAM WHICH HELPS ELIGIBLE
HOMEOWNERS CATCH UP WITH HIM IS
MONIES PAYMENTS. BY WE ARE ALL
CALLING TECHNOLOGY FACING WORK
IS OF WHAT IS NEEDED TO SOLVE
THE MASSIVE HOMEOWNERSHIP
CHALLENGING CALIFORNIA. AND AS
THE LEGISLATURE CONTEMPLATES
POSSIBLE POLICY APPROACHES WE
WOULD ENCOURAGE YOU TO CONSIDER
THE FOLLOWING THOUGHT. FIRST
WEALTH CREATION ANY
HOMEOWNERSHIP INTERVENTION MUST
CREATE THE OPPORTUNITY FOR
WEALTH CREATION THROUGH EQUITY
GAINS THIS IS PARTICULARLY
IMPORTANT TO REVERSE THE RACIAL
WEALTH GAP SECOND SUSTAINABILITY
HOMEOWNERSHIP SHOULD BE
SUSTAINABLE HOME BUYERS SHOULD
BE ABLE TO SUSTAIN
HOMEOWNERSHIP. OVER THE LONGER
THIRD SCALABILITY IN ORDER TO
FUNCTION ON A SCALE ON AN
ONGOING BASIS WE BELIEVE THE
FINANCIAL INSTRUMENTS MUST BE
DELIVERABLE TO THE SECONDARY
MARKET AND MUST BE DESIGNED TO
LEVERAGE LARGE SUMS OF PRIVATE
CAPITAL. IN ADDITION ANY
SOLUTION AT SCALE WILL REQUIRE
PARTNERSHIPS WITH FEDERAL ENTITY
SUCH AS FANNIE MAE FHFA AN FHA.
AND THEN LASTLY BUT BUT
DEFINITELY NOT LEAST. THE LINE
USE AND PERMITTING FOCUS SHOULD
CONTINUE TO BE ONLINE USE AND
PERMITTING INTERVENTIONS THAT
WILL INCREASE SUPPLY
COMMENSURATE. WITH THE BANK
IMPACTS RC AND THIS IS OF COURSE
TIED TO THE WORK OF OUR
COLLEAGUES AT A TV THAT CONTINUE
TO THE END OF THE CONTINUE TO
UNDERTAKE TO INCREASE LOCAL OF
ACCOUNTABILITY AND REGULATORY
CERTAINTY IN THE MARKET. I WANT
TO THANK THE COMMITTEE FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK ON THIS
IMPORTANT TOPIC- WE DO SEE THIS
AS AN ONGOING CONVERSATION AND
WE ARE HAPPY TO TAKE ANY
QUESTIONS THANK YOU SO MUCH.
THANK YOU THANK YOU FOR THAT DO
WE HAVE A MISTER CALDERON THE
LINE AS WELL. ASM EIGHT CD. YES
I'M CAN YOU HEAR ME CHURCH VIDEO
YES PLEASE GO AHEAD OKAY GREAT-
GOOD AFTERNOON YOUR CARDIO
ENSURE WICKS MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS BETH BROKE
OUT BY ONE OF THE DEPUTY
DIRECTOR FOR LEGISLATION AT THE
PARK AND HOUSING AND COMMUNITY
DEVELOPMENT. THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO PROVIDE TESTIMONY
AT TODAY'S HEARING I'M JOINED BY
MY COLLEAGUE JENNIFER SEGER PARK
DEPUTY DIRECTOR FOR STATE
FINANCIAL ASSISTANCE WHO CAN
HELP ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS YOU
MAY HAVE. HCP'S IS TO PROMOTE
SAFE AFFORDABLE HOMES AND
VIBRANT INCLUSIVE SUSTAINABLE
COMMUNITIES FOR ALL
CALIFORNIANS. BIKER COUNTERPARTS
THE COUCH OF BANK AT THE PARK
AND SHARES THE GOAL OF NARROWING
THE RACIAL WEALTH GAP. THE
CREATING AFFORDABLE AND
SUSTAINABLE COMMUNITIES GROW
CALIFORNIANS. I'M GOING TO FOCUS
MY COMMENTS ON COUNCIL THE
DEPARTMENT'S FLAGSHIP
HOMEOWNERSHIP PROGRAM. I'M GONNA
GIVE YOU A SENSE OF ALL THE WAYS
THAT EACH TV PROMOTES AFFORDABLE
HOMEOWNERSHIP. TO COMPLEMENT THE
WORK OF OUR COLLEAGUES A COUCH
AFFECTING HCV WITH LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS AND NONPROFIT TO
PROMOTE HOMEOWNERSHIP SOLUTIONS.
THAT RESPOND TO LOCAL
CONDITIONS. THESE PROGRAMS ARE
SET BY STATUTE AND INCLUDE
FUNDING BUT THE LEGISLATURE
PROVIDES USB TO. FOR THE
PERMANENT LOCAL HOUSING
ALLOCATION AND THE LOCAL HOUSING
TRUST FUND PROGRAMS. THESE TWO
PROGRAMS FIND THINGS LIKE DOWN
PAYMENT ASSISTANCE- INCREASE
FUNDING FOR LOCAL. HOUSING TRUST
FUNDS AND THE DEVELOPMENT OF
AFFORDABLE WORKFORCE HOUSING.
THIS WORK IS BUT BY FEDERAL
INVESTMENTS THROUGH CDBG AND
HOME WHICH ALSO PROVIDE FUNDING
TO JURISDICTIONS SET UP FIRST
TIME HOME BUYER PROGRAMS LIKE MR
MINETTI IN TOUCH UPON SUPPORT
THE DEVELOPMENT OF AFFORDABLE.
HOUSING AND PROVIDE FUNDING FOR
LOW INCOME VOTERS TO BE HELP
THEIR HOMES. XPB ALSO PROMOTES
AFFORDABLE HOMEOWNERSHIP. AND
THROUGH THE IMPORT HOUSING
SUSTAINABLE COMMUNITIES PROGRAM
- I WANT TO ALSO NOTE THAT
THANKS TO YOUR LEADERSHIP H. C.
B. S. STANDING UP IN NEW FIVE
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLAR
FORECLOSURE INTERVENTION
PREVENTION PROGRAM WHICH WILL
HELP STABILIZE EXISTING LOW
INCOME EARNERS AND TENANTS
LIVING IN PROPERTIES THAT ARE
SUBJECT TO FORECLOSURE. NOT TO
GET THE CAPITAL. THAT'S AS I
MENTIONED HDDS WATCH A
HOMEOWNERSHIP PROGRAM. TWENTY
EIGHTEEN TO TWENTY TWENTY ONE
THE STATE HAS INVESTED OVER ONE
HUNDRED AND SEVENTY ONE BILLION
IN THIS PROGRAM THE MAJORITY OF
THIS FUNDING COMING FROM WATER
BOX CAL HOME SUPPORTS LOCAL
AFFORDABLE HOMEOWNERSHIP
PROGRAMS AND UNIQUELY PROVIDES
FUNDING FOR PROJECTS THAT HAVE A
SELF HELP COMPONENTS LIKE THOSE
BUILT BY HABITAT FOR HUMANITY
AND SO. HOUSING ALL THE USERS OF
. ARE SO STATURE HCV PRIORITY
ONE STRAP THAT HAVE DEMONSTRATED
. IN SETTING UP THESE HOMEOWNERS
PROGRAMS. AND DEMONSTRATE THAT
KEPT OF THE BOAT A FOR
HOMEOWNERSHIP HOUSING SOME OF
THE USERS INCLUDE DOWN PAYMENT
ASSISTANCE REHAB FOR LOW INCOME
HOMEOWNERS SELF HELP MARKET YOUR
SYSTEMS- FOR PUNK ROCK HOUSING
DEVELOPERS CAL FROM FUNDS THINGS
LIKE BONES TO DEVELOP PROJECTS
THAT ARE MULTI FAMILY.
AFFORDABLE OWNERSHIP OF IT FUNDS
THINGS LIKE CONSTRUCTION LOAN
SITE DEVELOPMENT PRE DEVELOPMENT
LOANS. AND IN TWENTY TWENTY ONE
THE PROGRAM MADE A TOTAL OF
SIXTY SEVEN MILLION AVAILABLE
FOR HOMEOWNERSHIP PROGRAMS
THROUGHOUT THE STATE WITH THE
FUNDING BEING GEOGRAPHICALLY
DISTRIBUTED ACROSS CALIFORNIA.
THE DEPARTMENT EXPECTS TO
ANNOUNCE THE LATEST BATCH OF CAL
HOME IN EARLY MARCH UP I CAN
SHARE WITH YOU WHAT WE'VE DONE
IN TWENTY NINETEEN TO TWENTY
TWENTY. IS THAT CALIFORNIA HAS
HELPED OVER SIXTEEN HUNDRED
CALIFORNIA FAMILIES ACHIEVE
HOMEOWNERSHIP INCLUDING THE
CONSTRUCTION OF A HUNDRED AND
SEVENTY EIGHT AFFORDABLE
HOMEOWNERSHIP. THE PROGRAM HAS
BEEN AND CONTINUES THE
OVERSUBSCRIBED IT WAS
OVERSUBSCRIBED FORTY ONE IN
TWENTY NINETEEN AND THREE TO ONE
IN TWENTY TWENTY. AND LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS ACROSS THE STATE
MAKE USE OF THE PROGRAM FROM THE
SALIENCE OF LOS ANGELES WITH THE
BIGGEST TOPIC BEING IN SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA. YOUR OTHER COMPONENT
OF CAL BUT I WANTED TO HIGHLIGHT
FOR YOU IS THAT IT HAS ALSO BEEN
CRITICAL TO HELP OUR STATE
RECOVER FROM DEVASTATING
WILDFIRES. SINCE TWENTY EIGHTEEN
THE CAO HOME DISASTER RELIEF
PROGRAM HAS PROVIDED A HUNDRED
AND THIRTEEN BILLION TO HELP
GOING TO HOMEOWNERS REBUILD
THEIR HOMES. EACH CITY HAS
PRIORITIZE THE FUNDING FOR PARKS
IN THE STATE WITH THE MOST
STRUCTURES LOST AND JUST A FEW
TOP LINE HIGHLIGHTS FROM THAT IS
THAT- TWENTY TWENTY ONE WE
INVESTED FORTY ONE MILLION
DOLLARS TO HELP WITH WILDFIRE
RECOVERY EFFORTS AND- WE EXPECT
TO ANNOUNCES AWARDS IN MARCH.
AND IN TWENTY NINETEEN TO TWENTY
TWENTY THE LION SHARING 95% OF
HOUSEHOLDS DISASTER RELIEF
FUNDING WAS USED TO HELP PAY FOR
THE RECONSTRUCTION OF POST LOST
WHAT BUYERS. WITH THIRTY EIGHT
MILLION OR 55% OF BACK FROM. THE
COUNTY OF BUTTE COUNTY. AND THE
COUNTY OF SONOMA WHICH WERE MOST
IMPACTED IN YOUR FUTURE WE'RE
GOING TO CONTINUE INVESTING-
TELL HOME TESTOSTERONE BELIEVE
DOLLARS AN OWNER OCCUPIED
GREENHOUSE. TO HELP ALL COUNTIES
IMPACTED BY OUR WILDFIRES FOR
COPPER. SO I'M THANK YOU AGAIN
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO PRESENTS
ON ATVS HOMEOWNERSHIP PROGRAMS
AND I LOOK FORWARD TO CONTINUING
OUR PARTNERSHIP WITH YOU TO
CREATE AFFORDABLE HOUSING
OPTIONS FOR THE GREATEST NUMBER
OF CALIFORNIANS AND- I'M HAPPY
TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS YOU MAY
ASK. THINK YOU DO HAVE ANY
QUESTIONS FROM THE DIETS. MEMBER
SOMETIMES. CAN A QUESTION FOR MR
MARTY WE ADDED MORE FOR INTO THE
DUMP THIS. PROGRAM WHAT WOULD
THAT DO- DOES THAT INCREASE THE
AMOUNT OF ASSISTANCE PER
APPLICANT OR DO WE- HELP MORE
APPLICANTS WITH ASSISTANCE.
THANK YOU THANK YOU FOR YOUR
QUESTION CHAIR- DON'T EVEN
ASSISTANCE HE'S ARE HIGHLY
DEPENDENT ON THE REAL ESTATE
MARKET CYCLE SO- WE ARE
CURRENTLY DEPLOYING. THIS
SUFFICIENT AMOUNT OF FUNDS TO
COVER THE DEMAND AND IN
ADDITION- WE ARE ALSO. IN THE
PROCESS OF STANDING UP- THE NEW
COME AND YOU'LL HAVE FINANCIALPRODUCT THAT WILL ADDRESS-
HOMEBUYER ASSISTANCE ON THE
LOWER END OF THE HOME BUYER IN
INCOME SPECTRUM AROUND 80% OF A
IT MIGHT- WE ARE LOOKING TO
PROVIDE SUBSTANTIALLY HIGHER
LEVELS OF- DOWN PAYMENT
ASSISTANCE AND OUR CURRENT
PROGRAM IN THIS TO YOU- PRODUCT-
BECAUSE WE WILL BE SERVING A
MORE TARGETED POPULATION WILL
ALSO BE LOOKING TO ALLOW. MUCH
FASTER EQUITY BUILDING WITH
PERHAPS THE DPA OF BECOMING AN
GRANT AFTER A FEW YEARS IN THE
BORROWER STAYS IN THEIR HOME-
BUT OF COURSE WE WILL ALSO BE ON
MAINTAINING A STRONG FOCUS ON
SUSTAINABLE HOMEOWNERSHIP AS WE
ALWAYS DO AND THIS PROGRAM. IS
FUNDED. THIS NEW PRODUCT WILL BE
FUNDED WITH. EIGHTY EIGHT
DOLLARS PROVIDED INTO IN THE
LAST BUDGET- HAS- WEEKS TO LONG
SOMETIME AROUND EIGHT. SO MORE
DETAILS COME SO THAT IT I CAN
THAT IS. THE R. KIND OF FACE. UP
TO THE PLANE ON DUMPING
ASSISTANCE AND ANY MORE WAY I'LL
OPEN IT UP TO CALL ARE. CAN AND
ALONG THE HAVE ANYTHING HIDE.
THANK YOU FRIENDS- ALLEN MARTIN
DIRECT OF THE AND STICK WITH
RELATIONS WITH TO AFFECT- YEAH I
JUST WANT TO UNDERSCORE WHAT
PRINCESS STARTED WITH WHICH IS
THAT THE DEPLOYMENT OF OUR MY
HOME ASSISTANCE IS REALLY
LARGELY DEPENDENT. THE REAL
ESTATE CYCLE AND- THE ABILITY
FOR OUR HOME BUYERS TO ACCESS
HOMES THAT ARE AFFORDABLE- AND
THERE'S A NUMBER OF CHALLENGES
AND HEADWINDS AS I THINK WE ALL
KNOW RELATED TO INTEREST RATES
AND THE INFLATIONARY
ENVIRONMENT- AS AS WELL AS AS
RAPID HOME PRICE APPRECIATION.
YEAH AND WE LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH THE COMMITTEE ON
THIS NEW PRODUCT AND PROVIDING
MORE INFORMATION. LET'S SAY
YOU'RE AT THE- THAT MY QUESTION
IS ALMOST ANSWERED- WHEN YOU'RE
TALKING ABOUT WEALTH BUILDING
AND HOME EQUITY. IF YOU'RE
ENTERING A MARKET WHERE WE ARE
RIGHT NOW- YOU REALLY RUN THE
RISK OF HAVING JUST THE OPPOSITE
EFFECT YOU CAN DUMP A BUNCH OF
MONEY INTO GETTING PEOPLE INTO
HOMES THAT THEY LOSE A YEAR
LATER- BECAUSE V. TAKE TWO
THOUSAND EIGHT TWO THOUSAND
NINE. HOUSES WERE UPSIDE DOWN BY
AS MUCH AS FIFTY TO SIXTY
PERCENT- SHORTLY AFTER- IT
WITHIN A YEAR OR TWO OF PEOPLE
BUYING THEM AT THE TOP OF THE
MARKET. SO WE GIVES PEOPLE THE
RENTAL ASSISTANT ARMY IN THE
DOWN PAYMENT ASSISTANCE NOW AND
THEN NEXT THING WE HAD A
RECESSION. AND USUALLY IF
THEY'RE ON THE LOWER INCOME
SPECTRUM THEIR JOBS OR A LOT OF
TIMES AT RISK. HOW DO YOU COME
TO GRIPS WITH THE- YOU KNOW WHAT
THE FOR THE ECONOMIC FALLOUT
BECAUSE IT ONCE YOU GO DOWN THAT
PATH AND YOU'VE LOST EVERYTHING
. IT'S VERY VERY DIFFICULT FOR
PEOPLE TO GET BACK SO THAT THE
DID THEY JUST DEBTS PREVIOUS
PERSON JUST TALK ABOUT MARKET
TIMING. AND WHETHER THE THAT
WHEN THESE PROGRAMS ARE
EFFECTIVE AND THAT'S WHAT THE
SOMETHING I THINK WE REALLY NEED
TO TAKE INTO EFFECT WHAT'S YOUR
OPINION OF THAT IS WE REALLY
HAVE TO. HAVE THESE PROGRAMS
AVAILABLE WHEN THEY'RE EFFECTIVE
BECAUSE IF THERE'S NO EQUITY TO
BUILD THAT'S NOT GOING TO BE A
WEALTH BUILDER FOR PEOPLE IT'LL
BE A BIRD. THANK YOU FOR THE
QUESTION- I CAN I COULD TAKE A
STAB AT ANSWERING THAT- TO.
SUSTAINABLE HOMEOWNERSHIP IS A
FUNDAMENTAL PILLAR OF OUR
PROGRAMS I CUT TO PAY ANY AND
IT'S A FUNDAMENTAL PILLAR OF OUR
EXISTING PROGRAMS IT IS
DEFINITELY A FUNDAMENTAL PILLAR
ALL THIS NEW PRODUCT WERE.
PLANNING ON LAUNCHING IN THE
NEXT FEW MONTHS- WE DON'T WE
WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT WHICH IS
STILL FULL OF FOCUS NOT JUST ON
GETTING HOMEOWNERS IN INCOME IN
THE FIRST HOME. BUT ALSO WANT TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE DO SO BY
OFFERING PRODUCTS KIND ON ALSO
INDICATION OPPORTUNITIES THAT
WILL EQUIP THEM TO BE SUCCESSFUL
HOMEOWNERS SO THEY CAN STAY IN
THEIR HOME FOR THE LONG TERM.
AND I THINK THIS IS THE KEY TO
DROOL INTERGENERATIONAL WEALTH
BUILDING- WE AGREED THAT THE
ACCORDING TO OF SUSTAINABLE
HOMEOWNERSHIP WAS UNDERSCORED BY
THE TWO THOUSAND EIGHT.
FORECLOSURE CRISIS WHICH WAS
ABSOLUTELY DEVASTATING TOO MANY
<c.green>ALIFORNIANS. UP WITH LONG TERM</c>
IMPACTS ON FINANCIAL STABILITY
CREDIT AND OVERALL WILL BE OUR
FOR ALL OF DOWN PAYMENT
ASSISTANCE PRODUCTS. ARE PAIRED
WITH MORTGAGES THAT ARE FULLY
FEDERALLY CONFORMING SO THERE-
YOU KNOW FULLY CONFORMING TO
FINANCE. XCERRA RULES AND- HELLO
MY COLLEAGUES HELLO AND CHERYL
SPEAK A LITTLE BIT MORE. TO THAT
. SO YEAH- JUST TO SORT OF BUILD
ON WHAT FRAN WAS THE ARE UNDER.
GUIDELINES ARE FULLY CONFORMING
WITH THE GSES WHICH I THINK IS
IMPORTANT TO PROVIDING THAT
HOMEOWNERSHIP PROTECTION- THAT
HE ASSEMBLYMEMBER'S MENTIONING
SO- AGREED THAT THAT SUSTAINABLE
HOMEOWNERSHIP IS ABSOLUTELY
FOUNDATIONAL TO THIS ISSUE- AND
WE WANT TO BUILD ON LESSONS THAT
THAT WE LEARNED FROM THE TWO
THOUSAND EIGHT FINANCIAL CRISIS. YEAH IT SEEMS TO ME THE KEY TO
THAT IS THE ABILITY TO MAINTAIN
AND HOLD A PROPERTY. FOR OVER
TEN TO TWENTY YEARS THAT'S WHEN
YOU GET YOUR EQUITY BILL THAT.
BUT IF YOU CAN'T SURVIVE THE
FIRST FIVE OR FIRSTHAND. THEN
ALL YOU'RE DOING IS YOU'RE IN A
CYCLE THAT YOU'LL NEVER GET OUT
OF AND YOU KEEP DAMAGING YOUR
FINANCES WORSE AND WORSE ALONG
THE WAY. SO THAT'S WHAT MY
CONCERN IS MAKING SURE IT'S THE
TIMING IS RIGHT TO BE ABLE TO
HELP PEOPLE SO THAT THEY CAN
SUSTAIN IT. THIS WEEK'S THANK
YOU I'M JUST CURIOUS- EIGHT CD
IF YOU COULD TALK ABOUT HOW MY
UNDERSTANDING IS THE PROP ONE
DOLLARS TO FUND CAL HOME ALMOST-
DONE IF YOU COULD TALK THROUGH
HOW YOU'RE PLANNING ON IT BEING
FUNDED THAT BE GREAT. THANK YOU
FOR THE QUESTION CHAIR WICKS-
OKAY AND YOU ARE RIGHT THAT- CAL
HOME IS FUNDED THROUGH ONE
DOLLARS WE ARE WE DO HAVE ENOUGH
FUNDING BURKE CHIU ADDITIONAL
CYCLES- NOTICES OF FUNDING
AVAILABILITY AND WE EXPECT- THE
FUNDING FOR THIS PROGRAM TO RUN
OUT IN 200-023-2020 FOUR SO WE
DO HAVE SOME BROADWAY THERE- OF
COURSE THERE IS THE GENERAL
QUESTION OF HOW TO CONTINUE
PROMOTING. HOMEOWNERSHIP THROUGH
STATE PROGRAMS AND WE ARE GOING
TO CONTINUE TO HAVE THAT
CONVERSATION WITH YOU AS FUNDING
FOR THIS PROGRAM CONTINUES TO
DIMINISH. THANK YOU. THANK
AFFECTS MEASURE- COULD YOU GIVE
US OF JUST- HOW MAY. PEOPLE ARE
FAMILIES WERE ASSISTED IN.
TWENTY TWENTY OR TWENTY NINETEEN
I DON'T I DON'T KNOW WHAT YEARS
YOU HAVE NUMBERS FOR JUST GIVE
US A SENSE OF SCALE AND. ARE YOU
REFERRING TO THE- COACH A FEW
PROGRAMS OR THE TO THE WHOLE OR
TO CALL HOME I DON'T THINK
WHATEVER. WHATEVER NUMBERS YOU
HAVE WATER YOU'VE TALKED ABOUT A
NUMBER OF PROGRAMS YOU HAVEN'T
REALLY GIVEN US A SENSE OF-
WHO'S BEEN HELPED. YES
ABSOLUTELY SO IN THE LAST EIGHT
WITH ARE MY HOME DOWN PAYMENT
ASSISTANCE PROGRAM WE SHOULD
ABOUT SEVEN THOUSAND SIX HUNDRED
FIRST TIME HOME BUYERS IN THE
LAST FISCAL YEAR- AND- HOLD THE
FRUIT AND ALL DIFFERENT TO-
LIKELY PEDRO AND CALL HOME. BUT
I'M JUST GONNA I DID IN MY-
STATEMENT EARLIER- JUST KIND OF
KNOW THAT ARE ON THE HOME. IS
HIGHLY DEPENDENT ON THE REAL
ESTATE MARKET CYCLE SO DOING AT
UP CYCLE- WE COULD SETTLEMENT AS
THIRTEEN THOUSAND FIRST HOME
BUYERS- PORTANTINO WHEN THE
MARKET GOES OFF WE CAN BE ME SIR
MAYBE SOME SOME SOME. AROUND SIX
THOUSAND SO HILARIOUS BUT MOST
RECENT NUMBERS. SEVEN THOUSAND
SIX HUNDRED. I THANK YOU FOR THE
CAR CHURCH- OR CAN HOME IN
TWENTY NINETY. AND TWENTY
TWENTY. WE SERVE SIXTEEN HUNDRED
HOUSEHOLDS- WITH THE PROGRAM
WITH A RANGE OF MOTORSHIP
PROGRAMS- FOR TWENTY TWENTY ONE
WE EXPECT TO HAVE THOSE FIGURES
SHORTLY I'M THOSE AWARDS ARE
GOING TO BE ANNOUNCED IN EARLY
MARCH. AND I CAN FOLLOW UP WITH
YOUR OFFICE AND GET THEM TO YOU
. GREAT THANK YOU. ARE YOU
GOODNESS THANK OKAY THANK YOU-
OTHER QUESTION WITH REGARDS TO
JUST GENERAL- AVAILABILITY HAVE
YOU ENCOUNTERED SITUATIONS WHERE
DESPITE HAVING A REALLY GOOD
APPLE CANTON EVERYTHING'S IN
ORDER AND YOU HAVE THE FINANCES
AVAILBLE BUT YET THERE'S
SOMEONE ELSE THAT COMES IN MAYBE
SOME FOREIGN INVESTMENT WITH
CASH DOLLARS TO TAKE THAT HOME
AWAY FROM. THE A PERSON OR THE
FAMILY THAT YOU'RE TRYING TO
SUPPORT. SO I'LL STOP THANK YOU
FOR THE QUESTION- CHAIR THAT'S A
THAT'S A REALLY GOOD QUESTION I.
I'LL JUST START BY SAYING THAT-
OUR PROGRAM LIKE IT DIDN'T IT IN
ORDER TO THE TIMELINE THAT WE TO
CLOSE ON HOME WITH OUR TEMP
ASSIST IS VERY CAN. WITH THE
MARKET CHANNEL- SO WE ARE VERY
PROUD OF THAT- SPECIFICALLY
ABOUT A COMPETITIVE NESTS WITH
OF KIND OF. FOREIGN INVESTORS OR
OTHER TYPES OF BUYERS HELLO. LET
MY COLLEAGUES- COLANGELO TO SEE
THAT'S SOMETHING THAT THE
COMPANY KIND OF ANECDOTAL. AND
THAT IN ITSELF BUT- BUT- TO A
I'D LIKE TO COME OF REMARK THAT
. WE ARE CAN WITH- WITH A NORMAL
TYPES OF BUYERS IN KIND OF A
KIND ARE. THIS IS YOUR LINKS TO
THE CALIFORNIA HOUSING FINANCE
AGENCY- IN OUR LINE OF BUSINESS
WE DEAL DO NOT DEAL WITH
CONSUMERS DIRECTLY SO WHEN WE
GET THE LOANS THEY HAVE ALREADY
GONE THROUGH A LENDING PROCESS
AND HAVE BEEN VETTED SO ANY
FALLOUT WOULD HAVE HAPPENED
BEFORE WE EVER SEE AT. WHAT ONE
MOMENT THAT'S NOT NECESSARILY
WHAT I'M ASKING SO. I'M ASKING
IS YOU HAVE YOU HAVE A PERFECT
CANDIDATE YOU HAVE A SOMEONE
THAT'S BEEN VETTED. YOU'RE GOING
THROUGH THE PROCESS OF- MAYBE
FINDING THE PERFECT HOME. AND
THEN THE HOMEOWNER DECIDES TO
TAKE THE OFFER FROM. SOMEONE
THAT HAS ALL CASH. AND SOMEONE
IS COMING FROM OUTSIDE THE
COUNTRY LIKE A FOREIGN INVESTOR.
WHICH IS SOMETHING THAT WE SEE
QUITE A BIT IN LOS ANGELES I'M
I'M CURIOUS IF THAT'S- AN
EXPERIENCE THAT YOU HAVE. CHERYL
CHERYL I DON'T KNOW IF YOU HAVE
ANY KIND OF ANECDOTAL EVIDENCE
OF THAT. I HAVE NOT SEEN IN
ADELAIDE BUT INSTEAD THAT. I
THINK WE CAN SAY THAT IT IS A
HIGHLY COMPETITIVE MARKET- I
HIGHLY SUPPLY CONSTRAINED MARKET
AND SO YOU KNOW ALL BUYERS ARE
HAVING TO COMPETE WITH THOSE ALL
CASH OFFERS- THAT THAT REALLY.
ADDS ADDITIONAL DEMANDS AND
CREATES ADDITIONAL SUPPLY
CONSTRAINTS IN THE MARKET. THANK
YOU MISTER LUCKY. YEAH JUST REAL
QUICKLY OUT WE HAVE THE NUMBER
QUOTED TO US THAT THEY WERE
BENEFICIARIES TO THE TUNE OF
ABOUT SEVEN THOUSAND SIX
HUNDRED. AND I WAS WONDERING IF
THERE WERE ANY RURAL LEE LOCATED
HOME BUYERS THAT WERE BENEFITED
BY. THAT PROGRAM OR IF RURAL
APPLICANTS ARE EVEN ELIGIBLE. WE
ARE THANK YOU FOR THE QUESTION
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WERE MORE THAN
HAPPY TO PROVIDE YOU WITH- YOU
KNOW DIGIT GEOGRAPHIC
DISTRIBUTION OF OUR PROGRAM HOW
WE DO SEVERAL COUNTIES OF
COURSE- AND WE ALSO HAVE
PROGRAMS THAT ARE PAIRED WITH
USDA LOANS I SHALL I DON'T KNOW
IF YOU WANT TO SPEAK WITH A LIVE
MORE UP. HELLO GUYS AREN'T WE DO
I WOULD SAY THE MAJORITY OF OUR
BUSINESS IN TEN OF THE FIFTY
ACRE COUNTIES IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA YEAH IT'S- I'M- SORRY
APOLOGIZE AFTER OUR COUNTY SAN
JOAQUIN COUNTY- ST BERNARD DINO
LOS ANGELES PRINT PRIMARILY IN
THE- PALMDALE LANCASTER AREA-
CONTRA COSTA STANISLAUS COUNTY.
FRESNO COUNTY. ALTHOUGH WE DO WE
OFFER THEM OUR PROGRAM IN ALL
FIFTY EIGHT COUNTIES THAT WE
PRIMARILY TO OUR BUSINESS IN
THE- TEN COUNTIES WHICH IS THE
SAM THE CENTRAL VALLEY MAJORITY
COULD THE INDIRECTLY ANSWERS MY
QUESTION I'M I'M JUST TRYING TO
MAKE SURE THAT GOES AND MY
DISTRICT I HAVE AND SPECIALLY IN
THE ONE- I'VE BEEN NEWLY
ASSIGNED. IT'S RURAL SUPER SUPER
RURAL AND I JUST WANT TO MAKE
SURE THAT AND MANY OF THOSE
PEOPLE HAVE VERY LIMITED
INCOMES. AND I JUST WANT TO MAKE
SURE THAT THEY WERE BEING- CUT
OUT OF THIS THIS OPPORTUNITY. IT
FOR THE USDA PROGRAM WHICH IS
UP. ZERO COMMUNITIES. THANK YOU
SO MUCH IF THERE ARE NO
ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS FROM
MEMBERS OF THE DIETS WE'RE GOING
TO MOVE ON TO PANEL NUMBER THREE
WHICH- MY CO CHAIR ASSEMBLY
MEMBER WORKS WILL INTRODUCE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR OUR
FINAL PANEL. CHALLENGES TO
INCREASING HOMEOWNERSHIP WE WILL
START WITH TASHA HANNEMANN WHO'S
THE DIRECTOR OF THE BLACK
LEADERSHIP COUNCIL. THAN ONE
HERE JEFF SCHROEDER. AS V. P.
LAND. PLANNING OPERATIONS AND
PONDEROSA HOMES. FELL BY DEBBIE.
OUR CALVET EXACTLY DIRECTOR OF
HABITAT FOR HUMANITY. M. AND-
THOMAS CULLEN SHOP PRESIDENCY OF
SELF HELP ENTERPRISES TASHA ARE
YOU THERE. M. JOINING US. THANK
YOU GOOD AFTERNOON SHARE KERN
CHAIR REX AND MEMBERS OF THAT
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS TASHA
HANNEMANN I SERVICE CHIEF OF
POLICY- GOVERNMENT AFFAIRS FOR
PRC AND DIRECTOR OF THE BLACK
LEADERSHIP COUNCIL WHICH WHICH
I'M REPRESENTING TODAY I'M THE
BLACK LEADERSHIP COUNCIL IS MADE
UP OF CALIFORNIA LEADERS FROM
VARIED SECTORS THAT SEEKS TO
IMPROVE CONDITIONS AND CREATE
ECONOMIC PROSPERITY OF BLACK IN
LOW INCOME COMMUNITIES OF COLOR
ACROSS FOUR KEY PILLARS OF
HEALTH WEALTH HOUSING AND
HOMELESSNESS- IS THE EDUCATION.
POLICY ISSUES WE ARE CURRENTLY
RESEARCHING SUPPORTING AND OR
ADVOCATING FOR UNDER OUR HOUSING
POLITICALLY TO ADVANCE REGIONAL
EQUITY EQUITY WITHIN
HOMEOWNERSHIP SOME OF WHICH I AM
WHAT ARE ALSO IN OUR
RECOMMENDATION AND I'LL BE
PRESENTING. AND THAT HAVE BEEN
DISCUSSED TODAY. ALL RIGHT. SO I
JUST WANTED TO MENTION THAT THE
DECLINE IN BLACK HOMEOWNERSHIP
THREATENS TO EXASPERATION
ALREADY QUALITY FOR DECADES TO
COME AS HOMEOWNERSHIP REMAINS
THE PRINCIPAL WAY MOST FAMILIES
AND WORKED IN THIS COUNTRY AND
WE'RE HAVING SOME PROBLEMS IN
YOUR SCREEN I DON'T KNOW IF
THAT'S ON OUR END OR YOURS-
JUST- YEAH. THERE'S SOME GREAT
BLOCKS IN THE WAY. THE TAXES
WERE OKAY AT THIS AGAIN- WE WILL
. IS THAT BETTER THAT'S BETTER
THANK YOU OKAY SORRY ABOUT THAT
I DON'T KNOW WHAT THE ISSUE IS
HERE UP THERE BECAUSE UP THERE
IT'S BACK YEAH. OKAY WELL MAYBE
I WON'T SHARE- I WILL JUST TALK
THROUGH THE SLIDE DECK I'M NOT
SURE WHY THAT'S HAPPENING- OKAY
NOT THAT- ALL RIGHT WELL- AS
ALREADY MENTIONED HOMEOWNERSHIP
REMAINING A PRINCIPLE WAY MOST
FAMILIES BUILD WEALTH IN THIS
COUNTRY- THE WIRING TO
AFFORDABILITY GAP IN CALIFORNIA
BETWEEN WHITES AND PEOPLE OF
COLOR COMMANDS BOLD AND SWEEPING
SYSTEMIC REFORMS THAT REDUCE
BARRIERS TO OPPORTUNITY WEALTH
CREATION SO MUCH MORE- AS
ALREADY MENTIONED ALSO
CALIFORNIA'S BLACK HOMEOWNERSHIP
RATE HAS BEEN LOWER THAN IT WAS
IN THE NINETEEN SIXTIES WHEN
THERE WERE. COMPLETELY WHEN IT
WAS COMPLETELY LEGAL TO
DISCRIMINATE AGAINST BLACK HOME
BUYERS STILL MAJOR BARRIERS THAT
CONTINUE TO DEPRESS BLACK
HOMEOWNERSHIP INCLUDE CREDIT
STUDENT LOAN DEBT LACK OF
INFORMATION AND RESOURCES FOR
FIRST TIME ESPECIALLY FIRST
GENERATION HOME BUYERS IT CAN BE
EXTREMELY DEFEATING TO BE DENIED
MORTGAGE APPROVAL THEREFORE IT
IS CRITICAL TO INFORM THESE
INDIVIDUALS OF THEIR FINANCIAL
OCT. IT'S A HELP OR THEM TAX
RISK. IN AFFORDABLE HOME LENDERS
AND ENTERED THE HOME BUYER
MARKET POST. A COUNSELING CAN
ALSO SIGNIFICANTLY MITIGATE
DELINQUENCY PREVENTIVE PLACEMENT
AND GENTRIFICATION AND PRESERVE
WEALTH. THIS IS WHY THE BLC
FEELS VERY STRONGLY THAT THE
LEGISLATURE NEEDS TO TAKE
DELIBERATE ACTION WHICH TARGETS
THIS GENERATIONAL ISSUE OF BLACK
PEOPLE BEING LOCKED OUT INTO
NINE HOMEOWNERSHIP
OPPORTUNITIES. ULTIMATELY OPTING
IN ADDRESSING THE HISTORICAL.
LEGACY OF SYSTEMIC RACISM.
EXCELLENT RESEARCH BY MY STANLEY
EQUALIZING BLACK WHITE
HOMEOWNERSHIP RATES OVER THE
NEXT TEN YEARS WOULD CREATE MORE
THAN FIVE MILLION MORE
HOMEOWNERS OF COLOR. GENERATE
NEARLY EIGHT HUNDRED THOUSAND
NEW LONG TERM JOBS AND RAISE UP
TO FOUR HUNDRED MILLION IN
ADDITIONAL TAX REVENUES RELATIVE
TO CURRENT TRENDS. AND WHILE
SOME POLICY IMPROVEMENTS HAVE
LED THE WAY TO ADDRESSING MANY
DISPARITIES THAT BLACK AFRICAN
AMERICAN INDIVIDUALS FACE WHILE
EXPLORING ARE ACCESSING
HOMEOWNERSHIP. THERE'S STILL A
LONG WAY TO GO AS WE SEEK TO
APPLY EQUITY AND PARITY ACROSS
ALL COMMUNITIES- SO- SOME OF OUR
RECOMMENDATIONS- THE FIRST COME
FROM A REPORT FROM THE BROOKINGS
INSTITUTE. SO THAT WOULD BE TO
INCREASE SUPPORT FOR SMALL
DOLLAR MORTGAGE LOAN PROGRAMS
I'M IT IS A PERVASIVE MYTH THAT
HOME OWNERS OF LOWER VALUE ARE
RISKIER INVESTMENTS FOR
MORTGAGES BUT RECENTLY IN
ALICE'S FROM THE URBAN INSTITUTE
SHOWS THAT. THESE BUYERS ARE
COMPATIBLE CREDIT SCORES AND
THEIR MORTGAGES HAVE SIMILAR
LOAN TO VALUE RATIOS TO MORE
VALUABLE PROPERTIES AS HOMES IN
BLACK NEIGHBORHOODS ARE ALREADY
DEVALUED THIS BARRIER TO ENTRY
TO HOMEOWNERSHIP
DISPROPORTIONATELY AFFECTS BLACK
BUYERS ESPECIALLY THOSE WHO ARE
FIRST TIME HOME BUYERS- ANOTHER
RECOMMENDATION WOULD BE TO
REDUCE UNEVEN COST OF MORTGAGES
FOR BLACK HOMEOWNERS I'M
HOMEOWNERSHIP WHILE BLACK IS
EXPENSIVE. CREATING A RATE AND
TERM REFINANCE OPTION WOULD HELP
MORE HOUSEHOLDS REDUCE MONTHLY
MORTGAGE COSTS AND LOWER. THE
BARRIERS TO HOMEOWNERSHIP.
EXISTE CREDIT AND DOWN IS TO
BORROWERS IMPACTED Y
DISCRIMINATORY HOUSING AND
LENDING PRACTICES HISTORICAL AND
ONGOING POLICIES SUCH AS
REDLINING RESTRICTS THE
RESTRICTIVE COVENANT STEERING.
ANYMORE ARE HAVE EXTRACTED WELL
FROM BLACKLEY FOR GENERATIONS
AND WHILE IT'S NOT ENOUGH TO
SIMPLY EXTEND CREDIT BASED ON
REDLINING MAPS DRAWN IN THE NEW
DEAL ERA. PAST INJUSTICES MUST
BE REDRESSED BY HELPING TO
DEVELOP AREAS LEFT BEHIND BY
RACES POLICIES. ADULT CREDIT
SCORING PRACTICES WITH LESS
DISCRIMINATORY DISCRIMINATORY
IMPACTS CURRENT METRICS THE
CREDIT SCORING DO NOT ACCOUNT
FOR REGULAR PAYMENTS FROM RENT
AND UTILITIES INSTEAD THEY
PRIORITIZE LOAN AND CREDIT CARD
PAYMENTS. EXPANDING THE CHINS OF
CREDIT BUILDING CAN DISPEL THE
MYTH THAT BLACK HOMEOWNERS ARE
RISKY INVESTMENTS. INCREASE
DIVERSITY IN THE APPRAISAL
PROFESSION NEARLY NINE OF TEN
PROPERTY APPRAISALS ARE. ARE
PRAZERES SKEWS ME ARE WHITE
WHILE 2% ARE BLACK HI THIS IS
ACCORDING TO URBAN INSTITUTE
ANALYSIS IN TWENTY NINETEEN
CENSUS DATA. WITH DEMOCRATS
INSTANCE OF APPRAISER BIAS
MAKING HEADLINES ON A CONSTANT
BASIS BETTER REPRESENTATION IN
THE PROFESSION- HOLD SWAY OVER
AT THE MY MUCH OF THE VALIDATION
PROCESS AND CAN GO A LONG WAY.
MORE RECENTLY- I PERSONALLY MY
PARTNER WHO'S A BLACK MALE
PURCHASED A HOME LAST YEAR HE-
GOT HIS HOUSE THE BASE LAST YEAR
AND HE DID NOT. SHOW UP TO THE
APPRAISAL HE INSTEAD ASKED HIS
WHITE REALIST HER TO ATTEND ON
HIS BEHALF BECAUSE HE WAS
CONCERNED ABOUT THE BIAS THAT HE
MADE OR DISCRIMINATION THAT HE
MIGHT FACE IN THAT PROCESS AND
WE'VE HEARD THIS FROM MANY
MEMBERS AFTER- THE BLC JUST
DISCRIMINATORY- EXPERIENCES THAT
THEY'VE HAD IN ATTAINING-
PHONES. AND SO. WHEN I SING BIAS
YOU KNOW IT'S MORE THAN JUST
REQUIRING A TRAINING WHICH IS A
GREAT FIRST STEP BUT WE HAVE TO
CONSIDER MORE ACCOUNTABILITY
MEASURES. ARE PERHAPS THERE'S A
HOTLINE WHERE BIAS INCIDENCES
COULD BEREPORTED OR MORE
PERSONAL LIABILITY IF YOUR
APPRAISAL WAS FOUND TO BE
INDEED. ONE OF THE HIGHEST AT
THERE MAY PERHAPS MAYBE. A FINE
OR PENALTY TO BE CONSIDERED- AND
THEN LAST. BROUGH RECOMMEND THAT
CONTINUES. AND RELIEF EFFORTS
FOR HOME OWNERS AND BUYERS IN
THE WAKE OF CARPET NINETEEN SO
WE KNOW THAT THE PANDEMIC
EXASPERATED FINANCIAL HARDSHIP
FOR MANY AUNTS ADAM. AND THEN
THERE'S A FEW ADDITIONAL
RECOMMENDATIONS I'LL JUST
MENTION IN THERE LOOK A BIT TOO
TOOK A TOUR OF OUR FRIENDS
HABITAT FOR HUMANITY HERE ON THE
LINE AND THEY MAY SPEAK TO THEM
BUT THEY ARE LINED WITH THE
BOC'S AGENDA. AS WELL AS
BROOKINGS AND THAT'S JUST AGAIN
INVESTING IN AFFORDABLE HOW
NUMBER OWNERSHIP INCREASING
ACCESS TO DOWN PAYMENT
ASSISTANCE AND INCREASE ACCESS
TO AFFORDABLE CREDIT. LAST I
JUST LIKE TO POINT OUT THAT THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
REALTORS HAS BEEN INTRODUCED IN
SEVERAL FAIR HOUSING AND EQUITY
BILLS BUT ALSO ALIGNED WITH OUR
POLICY AGENDA- SO REQUIRING
CALIFORNIA REAL ESTATE
PROFESSIONALS TO TAKE IMPLICIT
BIAS TRAINING IS ONE OF THEIRS
AS WELL. REMOVING DISCRIMINATORY
LANGUAGE AND PROPERTY RECORDS
PROHIBITING DISCRIMINATION
AGAINST PEOPLE LIVING IN
AFFORDABLE HOUSING. REPEAL
ARTICLE THIRTY FOUR OF THE
CALIFORNIA CONSTITUTION. AND
BOOST HOUSING CONSTRUCTION SO
HOMEOWNERSHIP IS ACCESSIBLE TO
ON. SO I THINK YOU FOR YOUR TIME
TODAY I'M THRILLED TO NOTE
SLEGERS FOCUSING ON THIS- TO GET
THE BLACK AND AYE PART
COMMUNITIES ON LEVEL FOOTING TO
HOMEOWNERSHIP ESPECIALLY DURING
A TIME WHEN WE HAVE A HISTORIC
BUDGET SURPLUS TO SUPPORT AS
MANY FAMILIES ON THE PATH. TO
SELF SUFFICIENCY AS POSSIBLE IN
THIS CAN'T HAPPEN WITHOUT TAKING
INTENTIONAL ACTION TO CREATE
EQUAL OPPORTUNITY AND ACCESS FOR
EVERYONE SO IT'S FOR OUR FAMILY
THAT'S RIGHT FOR THE ECONOMY AND
IT'S RIGHT FOR OUR FUTURE. IN
THE BILL SEEKS TO BE HAPPY TO
PARTNER IN ANYWAY IN SUPPORT
YOUR EFFORTS SO I HOPE TO REMAIN
IN TOUCH THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MISS ADMIN APPRECIATE YOUR
TESTIMONY AND YOUR PERSONAL
STORY AND I'M SORRY THAT YOU'RE-
A PARTNER WENT THROUGH THAT- BUT
IF WE SHOULD BE SHARING THAT
WITH US. UP NEXT WHERE FROM-
MISTER AT JEFF SCHROEDER.
AFTERNOON SHARES CARILLO AND
WICKS IN MEMBERS OF THE ASSEMBLY
HOUSING COMMITTEE AND BUDGET SUB
COMMITTEE THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO REPRESENT CBI A
AND HOME BUILDERS ON THIS
IMPORTANT ISSUE MY NAME IS JEFF
STRAIGHTER AND VICE CHAIR OF CIA
AND SENIOR VICE PRESIDENT OF
LAND PLANNING OPERATIONS FOR
PONDEROSA HOMES WE ARE A BAY
AREA BASED HOMEBUILDER AND
CURRENTLY HAVE PROJECTS IN THE
BAY AREA THE CENTRAL VALLEY AND
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA. PROBABLY NO
CALIFORNIA'S BEEN UNDER BUILDING
HOUSES FOR OVER FORTY YEARS.
THERE ARE MANY REASONS FOR THIS
WHICH EXISTED PRIOR TO COPE
WITH. WHICH HAS MADE THINGS
WORSE MY FOCUS ON IS ON THE
UNDERLYING ISSUES. STATE AND
LOCAL POLICIES WHICH HAVE. IN
CONTINUE TO EXACERBATE THE
HOUSING CRISIS. AND MAKE NO
MISTAKE ABOUT IT WE ARE IN A
PROLONGED HOUSING CRISIS WITH NO
SIGNIFICANT RELIEF IN SIGHT. IN
MY THIRTY THREE YEARS IN THIS
BUSINESS. IT'S NEVER BEEN HARDER
TO BUILD HOUSING. SO WHAT CAN
YOU IS LEGISLATORS DUE TO HELP
SOLVE THE HOUSING CRISIS. NUMBER
ONE DO NO HARM IT SHOULD BE
PARAMOUNT THAT NO NEW
LEGISLATION IS PASSED THAT MAKES
IT HARDER TO SUPPLY HOUSING. A
RECENT ASSEMBLY SEQUEL BILL IS
AN EXAMPLE OF THAT
SIMPLIFICATION CAUSES
UNNECESSARY DELAYS AND ADDS TO
THE COST OF HOUSING OFTEN FOR NO
REAL BENEFIT. REGULATIONS
CONTINUE TO BE PROMULGATED WHICH
ADD TO THE COST OF HOUSING.
THOSE REVISIONS TO THE WATER
BOARD'S CONSTRUCTION GENERAL
PERMIT INCREASED ENERGY
EFFICIENCY REQUIREMENTS BY CC
WILL ADD THOUSANDS OF DOLLARS
PER UNIT HOUSING COSTS. WITH NO
SIGNIFICANT BENEFIT. WELL WE
UNDERSTAND THE IMPORTANCE OF
REGULATIONS PERHAPS WE SHOULD
RECONSIDER THE VALUE OF
ADDITIONAL REGULATIONS DURING
THIS HOUSING CRISIS. ONE
POSSIBLE SOLUTION WOULD BE TO
ENACT LEGISLATION WHICH DELAYS
NEW REGULATIONS FOR TEN YEARS.
NUMBER TWO IT'S ALL ABOUT SUPPLY
RESTRICTIVE LAND USE POLICIES
AND A BIAS AGAINST TRADITIONAL
SUBURBAN HOUSING HAVE DRIVEN
LANDED HOUSING PRICES THROUGH
THE ROOF. MANY SUBURBAN
COMMUNITIES RESIST GRANTING
ENTITLEMENTS FOR HOUSING TO
ACCOMMODATE COMPUTERS FROM
JOBCENTRE COMMUNITIES WHICH ARE
ALSO UNWILLING TO ALLOW ADEQUATE
HOUSING. URBAN GROWTH BOUNDARIES
RESTRICT LAND SUPPLY AND REYES
LAND PRICES. AS WE PUSH LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS TO INCLUDE MORE
HOUSING WITHIN CITY LIMITS LOCAL
COMMUNITIES REVOLT AND NOW WE
HAVE PROPOSED BALLOT MEASURES
THAT COULD ELIMINATE STATE
HOUSING MANDATES. ONE SOLUTION
MIGHT BE LEGISLATION THAT
ELIMINATES URBAN GROWTH
BOUNDARIES OR REQUIRE THEM TO BE
ADJUSTED BY ANNUALLY TO MEET
NEEDED HOUSING PRODUCTION. WE
ALSO NEED ADULT SUPERVISION OVER
LOCAL CONTROL. IF WE RELY LOCAL
CITIES AND COUNTIES TO ALLOCATE
LAND FOR NEEDED HOUSING THEIR
SELF INTEREST WILL NEVER DELIVER
SIGNIFICANT NEW SUPPLY. THERE
HAS TO BE A STATE REGIONAL
OVERSIGHT PROCESS WHICH ALLOWS
BUILDERS AND DEVELOPERS TO
OVERRIDE LOCAL LEGISLATIVE ACTS
BUT WE WILL NEVER SOLVE THE
HOUSING CRISIS. STATE
LEGISLATION LIKE READ THE RIDEAU
PROCESS SB NINE SB TEN THE WHAT
WELL INTENTIONED ARE FORCING
LOCAL COMMUNITIES TO ACCEPT
GROWTH ALLOCATIONS. THEY ARE
RELATIVELY THE MINIMA SOLUTIONS
AND SUBJECT TO USE. STATE
POLICIES FOCUSED ON DEVELOPING
WITHIN THE URBAN FOOTPRINT
IGNORE MARKET FORCES. FOR THE
PANDEMIC DEMOGRAPHERS NOTED THE
TRANSITION FROM URBAN TO
SUBURBAN AND RURAL DESTINATIONS
AND THE PANDEMIC ACCELERATED
THIS TREND. ONLY A SMALL PORTION
OF BUYERS ARE INTERESTED IN HIGH
DENSITY HOUSING AND THIS IS THE
MOST EXPENSIVE TYPE OF HOUSING
WE BUILT. OUR MARKET EXPERIENCE
IN RESEARCH RESEARCH INDICATES
THAT FAMILIES WANT SINGLE FAMILY
HOMES AND THEY'RE DRIVING
FURTHER TO GET THEM WE'RE
LEAVING THE STATE ENTIRELY. WE
CANNOT CONSERVE OUR WAY OUT OF
THIS PROBLEM WE UNDERSTAND THE
NEED TO PRESS LOCAL COMMUNITIES
TO ACCEPT MORE DENSITY AND
DIVERSITY. BUT REMEMBER WHERE
EXACTLY WE ARE ASKING EXISTING
COMMUNITY TO SOLVE THE HOUSING
CRISIS IN THEIR NEIGHBORHOODS.
WHAT WE REALLY NEED IS
INVESTMENT IN NEW COMMUNITIES
THAT PEOPLE WANT TO LIVE IN.
SUBURBAN COMMUNITIES WHERE HOMES
CAN BE AFFORDABLE BY DESIGN.
DEVELOPERS CAN BUILD AFFORDABLE
HOUSING AND LESS DENSE
CONFIGURATIONS WINDSCALE LOW OUT
. GIVE ME THE ENTITLEMENTS FOR
ONE THOUSAND UNITS AND I WILL
GIVE YOU ONE HUNDRED AND FIFTY
TO TWO HUNDRED AFFORDABLE HOMES
. THESE NEW DEVELOPMENT
OPPORTUNITIES DO NOT HAVE TO BE
FAR FLUNG CONVERSELY THERE ARE
MANY AREAS WHICH WOULD BE
CONSIDERED INFILL. FOR
SUBSTANTIAL AMOUNTS OF NEW
HOUSING CAN BE BUILT. DESIGNATE
NEW STATE SPONSORED PRIORITY
DEVELOPMENT AREAS WITH STATE
LEVEL JURISDICTIONS CIRCUMVENT
LOCAL CONTROL AND HOUSING SUPPLY
SUPPRESSION. CREATE NEW FRANK
FINANCING OPPORTUNITIES
INCLUDING POTENTIAL PROPERTY TAX
ADJUSTMENTS TO HELP FINANCE AND
MAINTAIN NEW INFRASTRUCTURE.
IT'S TIME TO TAKE BOLD ACTION IF
WE ARE TRULY TO ADDRESS THE
HOUSING CRISIS. DO NO HARM THE
INTO LEGISLATION REGULATION THAT
THE LAYS SUPPLY AND INCREASES
COSTS. REFORM LOCAL CONTROL WITH
REGIONAL AND STATEWIDE OVERSIGHT
AND APPEALS PROCESSES TO
INCREASE SUPPLY. INVESTED NEW
SUBURBAN COMMUNITIES TO ALLOW
MARKET MARKET FORCES TO DELIVER
THE HOUSING MADE BY ALL
CALIFORNIANS. WITHOUT SOLUTIONS
LIKE THESE STATE HOUSING POLICY
WILL NOT OF THIS CRISIS I
APPRECIATE YOUR TIME AND
OPPORTUNITY TO CONTRIBUTE TO
THIS DISCUSSION- AVAILABLE FOR
QUESTIONS IF YOU HAVE ANY THANK
YOU. THANK YOU MISTER SCHROEDER
NEXT WE HEAR FROM DEBBIE ORACLE
WHOSE EXEC DIRECTOR OF HABITAT
FOR HUMANITY. W. THEIR- YES I AM
GREAT GOOD AFTERNOON AND THANK
YOU FOR INVITING ME TO
PARTICIPATE ON THIS PANEL I
REPRESENT THE COALITION OF
HABITAT FOR HUMANITY AFFILIATES
THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA AND WE'RE
NONPROFIT HOMEBUILDERS ADVANCING
HOMEOWNERSHIP WITH LOWER INCOME
CALIFORNIANS AND WE BUILD MULTI
FAMILY MULTI LEVEL OF HIGH
DENSITY OWNERSHIP DEVELOPMENTS
AS WELL AS SINGLE FAMILY AND
JUST A REMINDER OF WHO WE SERVE
WE SERVE LOWER INCOME UP 280%
AND MY WITH A FEW EXCEPTIONS UP
TO MODERATE WE SERVE BLACK
INDIGENOUS AND PEOPLE OF COLOR.
AND IMPACT 80% OF HABITAT HOME
HOME BUYERS ARE BLACK AND BROWN
HOUSEHOLDS WE SERVE OLDER ADULTS
AND VETERANS THERE'S AN URGENT
NEED FOR CALIFORNIA TO INVEST IN
AFFORDABLE OWNERSHIP PRODUCTION
TO INCREASE THE SUPPLY
CALIFORNIA'S BEEN IGNORING THE
OWNERSHIP MODEL FOR DECADES AND
NOW THE FUNDING IS ACTUALLY
THERE BUT THE WILL IS NOT
INVESTING IN HOMEOWNERSHIP
PROVIDES A PATHWAY TO STABILITY
AND EQUITY. AND WE SEE THREE KEY
LEADERSHIP ACTIONS FIRST TO
ADDRESS THE LACK OF LEADERSHIP
WELL AND INVESTED OWNERSHIP
PROTECTION WE NEED TO STOP THE
DECADES LONG SHORTAGE OF FUNDING
THERE'S A FAILURE AND IN SOME
CASES AN ACTUAL REFUSAL TO
RECOGNIZE THAT AFFORDABLE
HOMEOWNERSHIP MODEL EFFECTIVELY
AND PERMANENTLY ADDRESSES OUR
HOUSING NEEDS CALIFORNIA HAS THE
MONEY AND WITH THE SURPLUS AND
BILLIONS OF FEDERAL FUNDS
INFUSED INTO CALIFORNIA YES
MEMBERSHIP PRODUCTION WAS
ENTIRELY LEFT OUT OF THE STATE
BUDGET AND ENTIRELY LEFT OUT OF
STATE ALLOCATED ARPA. FUNDS FOR
PRODUCTION. SECONDLY WE NEED TO
PROMOTE THE STRONG RETURN ON
INVESTMENT BENEFITS OF
CALIFORNIA DOLLARS IN TAXPAYER
DOLLARS WITH THE AFFORDABLE
OWNERSHIP MODEL. AND THIRD WE
NEED TO ENSURE A LONG TERM
COMPREHENSIVE AND EQUITABLE
APPROACH TO CALIFORNIA'S HOUSING
SOLUTIONS WE NEED TO SOLVE FOR
THE SHORT AND THE LONG TERM
HOUSING NEEDS WITHIN PRODUCTS
THAT INCLUDES OF COURSE
TRANSITIONAL EMERGENCY HOUSING
FOR THOSE WHO ARE AND HOUSE.
AFFORDABLE RENTAL AND AFFORDABLE
OWNERSHIP IT'S A YES AND TO MEET
ALL OF OUR NEEDS NOT AN EITHER
OR AND THERE'S A COST TO DOING
NOTHING THE LACK OF FUNDING
MEANS OWNERSHIP UNITS DO NOT GET
BUILT THIS KEEPS OUR SUPPLY LOW.
IT KEEPS OWNERSHIP RATES DOWN
AND WE NEED TO STOP PERPETUATED
THE WEALTH IN EQUITY AND THE
RACIAL INEQUITY CAUSED BY
DENYING THAT LOWER INCOME
HOUSEHOLDS. ACCESS TO OWNERSHIP
IF YOU'RE LOW INCOME YOU MIGHT
GET SOME HELP WITH RENTAL BUT WE
WON'T HELP YOU GET AHEAD. SO
TOGETHER WE NEED TO RECOGNIZE
THAT AS WE NEED TO SOLVE THE
HOUSING SHORTAGE BY INCLUDING.
AFFORDABLE OWNERSHIP MODELS AND
I'M GONNA DO A QUICK SHARE ABOUT
THE CAL HOME PROGRAM THAT WE HAD
A LITTLE BIT ABOUT EARLIER.
EUGENE'S. OKAY JUST CONFIRMING
THAT THEY REALLY CAN SEE THIS
THOUGH THE CALLUM IS V.
OWNERSHIP PROGRAM MEANING IT IS
THE ONLY PROGRAM THAT NONPROFITS
CAN ACCESS TO GET PRE
CONSTRUCTION DOLLARS AND
ACTUALLY INCREASE PRODUCTION AS
WE HEARD IT'S UNDERFUNDED AND
OVERSUBSCRIBED AND- GOOD NEWS WE
HAVE HEARD WE'VE BEEN TOLD THAT
IT WAS EXPIRING AFTER THIS YEAR
AND IT SOUNDS LIKE- THERE MIGHT
BE FUNDING FOR ONE ADDITIONAL
YEAR BUT EITHER WAY IT IS
RUNNING OUT. FOR IT THE FIVE
PREVIOUS YEARS FUNDING AT ALL
PROP ONE FUNDS WERE DEPLETED AND
THERE WAS NO OPTION FOR
OWNERSHIP PRODUCTION WHATSOEVER
WITH NEW PROP ONE MODEST FUNDING
WE HAVE HAD SEVERAL YEARS OF
FUNDING TO THE OFFICE BUT
THERE'S NO REPLACEMENT FUNDING
SO WE JUST HAVE A GLANCE- YOU
CAN SEE THE LAST THREE YEARS OF
NO FIVE THE AMOUNT THAT WAS MADE
AVAILABLE SO BETWEEN FIFTY SEVEN
AND SIXTY ONE MILLION THE AMOUNT
REQUESTED. OUR OUR EXCEEDS THAT
AND THEN IF YOU LOOK AT WHAT THE
SHORTFALL IS OVERALL AND WE'RE
LOOKING AT CLOSE TO TWO HUNDRED
MILLION- AND THEN THE FOLLOWING
YEAR ALMOST A HUNDRED MILLION
AND THEN ALMOST SEVENTY MILLION
SO THOSE ARE UNITS THAT ARE NOT
BEING BUILT AND JUST SPEAKING
FOR HABITAT WE HAVE A PIPELINE
OF SHOVEL READY PROJECTS THAT WE
WOULD BE ABLE TO DO IF. THERE
WASN'T AN INVESTMENT. SO ALL AND
I'LL CONTINUE CARE WITH
EMPHASIZING THAT THE OWNERSHIP
INVESTMENT PAYS OFF CALIFORNIA
JUST JUST YOU KNOW THERE'S LIKE
A GREY BOX OVER YOUR
PRESENTATION FOR SOME REASON.
OKAY LET ME SEE IF I OTHER YOU
GO- IT IS BACK. IT MIGHT BE ON
OUR SIDE I DON'T KNOW IF IT'S-
THE OTHER. YEAH SOME ARE AND
SOME ARE BOB UNDER OUR IT
ANYBODY IF YOU COULD EVER REALLY
TALK THROUGH. WHAT YOU HEARD ME
MENTION OKAY IT SEEMS TO BE FINE. THIS I HAVE YOU'RE YOU'RE GOOD
NOW. OKAY JERRY IT AGAIN OR A
DON'T KNOW. YES WERE WONDER YEAH
I KNOW THE TEAM HAS A COPY OF IT
IT MAYBE I CAN GET THE THERE TO
SHARE WITH OUR- YEAH IF YOU WANT
HAVE YOU HAVE YOUR FOLKS AND TO
US. WE HAVE IT WE HAVE IT I
APOLOGIZE. YEAH NO THAT'S OKAY
THAT'S OKAY. OKAY SO DIDN'T
REALLY WANT TO SHOW THIS TO L.
HOW OF SUBSCRIBE AND UNDER FUND
WHICH- THAT THE FEWER UNITS THAT
WERE ABLE TO PRODUCE. AND THE
SECOND KEY OPPONENT AT ELEMENT
OF THE OWNERSHIP MODEL IS THAT
IT'S A SINGLE ONE TIME
INVESTMENT BY GOVERNMENT ENTITY
CHEATS MULTIPLE GOALS SO. IT
ALLOWS THE ABILITY TO INCREASE
THE RATE OF OWNERSHIP IN
CALIFORNIA WHICH WE'RE TRYING TO
BOOST AND HELPS CLOSE THE RACIAL
WEALTH AND OWNERSHIP GAP AND
HELP ADDRESS DISCRIMINATORY
PRACTICES AND IT ENABLES THE
FINANCIAL STABILITY FOR
GENERATIONS TO COME. AND VERY
QUICKLY AND SURE AS LONG TERM
PERMANENTLY AFFORDABLE HOUSING
STOCK BY INCREASING THE SUPPLY
AND INCREASING HOME PRODUCTION
WITH HOME CONNECTION BEING THE
NUMBER ONE WAY TO COMBAT
INFLATION. SO WHAT I WHAT I
WANTED TO TOUCH ON IS WHAT THE
HOMEOWNERSHIP FUNDING STACK WHAT
THAT MODEL LOOKS LIKE IT SOUNDS
LIKE YOU HAVE. YOU HAVE A HAND
OUT SO- I RELUCTANTLY SHARES THE
BRAIN- I COULD TRY IT. ALL RIGHT
LET ME KNOW IF THAT WAS FAULTY
BUT IF WE LOOK HERE THIS IS ON
THE HABITAT MODEL- AGAIN THIS
RANGES FOR ACTUAL COST
THROUGHOUT THE STATE BUT THE
HOME PRICES FOR SEVENTY FIVE.
AND IF YOU LOOK AT THE FUNDING
SOURCES THE SIGNIFICANT AMOUNT
IS THE ACTUAL HOMEOWNER LOAN SO
THIS IS THE LOWER INCOME
HOUSEHOLDS THAT IS MAKING
UNAFFORDABLE NO MORE THAN 30% OF
THEIR INCOME TOWARD. AN
AFFORDABLE MORTGAGE AND THEN
WERE ABLE TO LEVERAGE WITH
PRIVATE FUNDRAISING DOLLARS IN
SOME CASES WE ARE ABLE TO USE
DOWN PAYMENT ASSISTANCE DOWN
PAYMENT ASSISTANCE IS A GREAT
PROGRAM BUT IT'S WORTHLESS IF WE
DON'T HAVE THAT SUPPLY WE NEED
THE HOMES IN CALIFORNIA TO BE
ABLE TO APPLY IT. AND THEN THE
GOVERNMENT FUNDING THAT MIGHT BE
THE CALHOUN PROGRAM BUT AGAIN
THAT'S A SEGMENT OF THIS THAT IS
THE ONE TIME INVESTMENT AND THEN
THE AFFORD BETTER AFFORDABILITY
RESELL RESTRICTIONS APPLY MAKING
SURE THAT. THE STAYS WITHIN THE
AFFORDABLE COOL. FOR I YOU THIS
IS MEMBER SHARON SO HAVOC ON THE
THAT THAT RESALE RESTRICTIONS
WHAT ARE THOSE EXACTLY AND I
UNDERSTAND KEEPING THIS AND
AFFORDABLE HOUSING POOL BUT HOW
DOES THAT THEN WORK AS FAR AS
WEALTH GENERATION FOR THE
INDIVIDUAL HABITAT OWNER. YES
THANK YOU FOR THE QUESTION- SO
WITH THAT HABITAT SALES
AGREEMENTS WE HAVE THE FIRST
RIGHT OF REFUSAL SO TYPICALLY-
IDEALLY HABITAT WOULD RE
PURCHASE AND THEN WE WOULD MAKE
THAT AVAILABLE TO ANOTHER
QUALIFIED LOWER INCOME.
HOUSEHOLDS IT HABITAT FOR SOME
REASON DID NOT REPURCHASE THERE
STILL AN AFFORDABILITY
RESTRICTION THAT ALLOWS THE
ORIGINAL OWNER TO BUILD MODEST
EQUITY SO THEY ARE EARNING
EQUITY BUT THEY'RE NOT ABLE TO
FLIP IT WITH THE EQUITY THAT.
THEY'RE NOT GOING TO GET A
WINDFALL PROFIT SO THERE'S A
SHARED AGREEMENT THAT IS SPELLED
OUT AT THE VERY BIG EARLY ON
DURING THE QUALIFICATION
THROUGHOUT THE PROCESS AND THE
INTENTION LIKE I SAID IS TO
BUILD MODEST EQUITY. A LOT OF
HOMEOWNERS ARE THEN ABLE TO SAVE
BECAUSE THEY HAVE THAT LOCKED IN
MORTGAGE AND ARE ABLE TO MOVE
INTO MARKET RATE HOUSING. THANK
YOU. AND IF YOU WANTED TO WRAP
UP. OKAY HAPPY TO WRAP UP- JUST
WANTED TO QUICKLY SAY THAT THE
AFFORDABLE OWNERSHIP MODEL
DOESN'T JUST SOUND THAT WE HAVE
DECADES OF EVIDENCE- ESPECIALLY
DURING THAT THE PANDEMIC THERE'S
COMPELLING EVIDENCE THAT ONLY 7%
OF HABITAT MORTGAGE HOLDERS WERE
LAID ON THE MORTGAGE AND ZERO
WERE AT RISK OF FORECLOSURE. SO
WE REALLY ARE ENCOURAGING YOUR
SHIP TO INVEST IN AFFORDABLE
HOMEOWNERSHIP PRODUCTION MAX
MIGHT STATE HOUSING INVESTMENTS
AND HABITAT IS HERE AS A PARTNER
WE WANT TO WORK TOGETHER TO HELP
SOLVE THIS CRISIS THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TIME AND ATTENTION. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
PRESENTATION AND ROLLING WITH
SOME OF THE TECH CHALLENGES
THERE- NEXT WE'LL HEAR FROM TOM
MCCALL AND SHOP PRESIDENCY OF
SELF HELP ENTERPRISES TOM EITHER
. THANK YOU VERY. ABOUT YOUR
WEIGHT SIX OH COMMITTEE MEMBERS
- I REPRESENTED OR- THAT'S-
WORKING SINCE NINETEEN SIXTY
FIVE IN THE SAN JOAQUIN VALLEY.
TO CREATE HOMEOWNERSHIP
OPPORTUNITIES- WE DO THAT IN
THREE DISTINCT STRATEGIES. BOB
FIRST IS WE HAVE AN ACTIVE
MUTUAL SELF HELP HOUSING
PROGRAM- AND THAT'S WHERE
FAMILIES BUILD THEIR OWN HOMES
WITH OUR HELP- THEY HELP EACH
OTHER AS WELL WE BILL TEN HOMES
AT A TIME AND THE WAY IT WORKS
IS THAT ALL HOME START. THE SAME
DAY. BUT NOBODY MOVES UNTIL A
TENER DONE SO IT'S REALLY THAT
SHARED LABOR. THAT MAKES THE
DIFFERENCE. THE SECOND STRATEGY
IS WE WORK WITH A NUMBER OF US
CITIES AND COUNTIES IN THE
VALLEY. TO HELP THEM OPERATE
HOMEBUYER ASSISTANCE PROGRAMS
THROUGH A VARIETY OF STATE AND
FEDERAL- SOURCES. AND THE THIRD
THING THAT WE DO IS WE PROVIDE
HOMEBUYER EDUCATION CREDIT
COUNSELING- AND LINKAGES TO
OTHER KINDS OF SUBSIDY PROGRAMS. LIKE SOME THAT WERE MENTIONED
TODAY. BOB ALL TOLD WE'VE- OVER
TEN. FAMILIES THROUGH THAT-
THOSE THREE STRATEGIES- ABOUT
SIXTY FIVE HUNDRED OF THOSE- ART
THROUGH OUR SELF HELP HOUSING
PROGRAMS THE RESULTS HAVE BEEN-
STABLE PERMANENT AFFORDABLE
HOUSING FOR LOW INCOME FAMILIES-
WITH WEALTH BUILDING OUTCOMES-
AND- PREDOMINATELY- BY FAR AND
AWAY. OF PEOPLE OF COLOR WELL
OVER 80% OF THE FAMILIES WHO
PARTICIPATED IN OUR PROGRAMS
HAVE BEEN CUT PEOPLE OF COLOR
MOST MANY OF WHICH HAVE BEEN
FARMWORKERS. OF LATINO DESCENT.
WITH COSTS IN HOME ABOUT VALUES
AND BY NEARLY 30% IN JUST THE
PAST YEAR AND SOME OF OUR
MARKETS. THE GAP. FOR FAMILIES
TRYING TO ACHIEVE HOMEOWNERSHIP
LOW INCOME FAMILIES IS
INCREASING. UP FOR PROJECTS THAT
WE HAVE THAT ARE IN PROCESS WE
CAN KEEP PRICES LOWER BECAUSE WE
DON'T HAVE A PROFIT MOTIVE- IT
IN THE SELF HELP PROGRAM THE
BULK OF THE LABOR IS PROVIDED
THROUGH SWEAT EQUITY SO SOME OF
THE LABOR INCREASES WE DON'T
HAVE TO BEAR. UP BUT THERE ARE
STILL MAJOR GAPS AND SO WITHOUT
RE. REHASHING SOME OF THE THINGS
THAT I ABSOLUTELY AGREE WITH
FROM- MY HABITAT COUNTERPART I
WILL MENTION A COUPLE OF A
PROGRAM IMPROVEMENTS THAT ARE
FAIRLY SPECIFIC IN NATURE THAT
WOULD REALLY HELP US DELIVER-
THESE THESE PROGRAMS TO MORE.
DESERVING HOMEBUYERS. FIRST CAL
HOME FOR PROGRAM HAS BEEN TO
ABOUT LOT. BUT IT CERTAINLY IS
THE BEST TOOL THAT WE'VE EVER
SEEN DEVISED BY THE STATE TO
ASSIST LOW INCOME. HOMEBUYERS
BOB BUT FIRST THE COMPETITION
FOR FUNDS NEEDS TO USE MORE
GRANULAR DATA. HAS AS A BASIC
METRIC AND NOT COUNTY WHAT DATA.
MAKES DIFFICULT FOR SOME SMALL
CITIES AND RURAL COMMUNITIES TO
COMPETE EFFECTIVELY FOR FUNDS.
SECONDLY WE NEED TO MAKE A
PROGRAM COMPATIBLE WITH PRIMARY
MORTGAGE PROGRAMS. SUCH AS THE
USDA RURAL DEVELOPMENT FIVE A TO
DIRECT MORTGAGE PROGRAM WHICH WE
USE EXTENSIVELY HERSELF UP
HOUSING PROGRAM- THERE ARE SOME
DIFFERENCES IN THE INCOME
REQUIREMENTS THAT. FRANKLY THE
STATE DOES NOT NEED TO APPLY
THAT COULD ALLOW THE USDA- OF
METRICS TO GOVERN. OUR THIRD
CALLUM PRO FUNDING NEEDS TO BE
MORE FLEXIBLE INCLUDING ALLOWING
FOR VERTICAL CONSTRUCTION COSTS-
IN RECENT- NOTICES OF FUNDING
AVAILABILITY THAT HAS NOT BEEN
ALLOWED WHAT IT HAS BEEN IN PAST
CYCLES. AND LASTLY THERE NEEDS
TO BE ONGOING FLEXIBILITY OF THE
LOAN AMOUNTS THAT ARE NEEDED
THAT CAN BE RESPONSIVE TO LOCAL
MARKET CONDITIONS. A WORD ABOUT
FEDERAL PROGRAMS THAT- ARE
PASSED THROUGH THE STATE.
DEPARTMENT HOUSING AND COMMUNITY
DEVELOPMENT- BOB AND LOCAL
GUIDELINES SHOULD SHOULD BE
FLEXIBLE AS LONG AS THEY CONFORM
TO THE REGULATIONS AND NOT ONE
SIZE FITS ALL AND I'M MOSTLY
REFERRING TO THE HOME AND CDBG
PROGRAMS WHICH CAN ALSO BE.
CRITICAL ASSISTANCE FOR FIRST
TIME HOMEBUYERS. BOB ALSO STATE
PROGRAMS SHOULD NOT DISCOURAGE
SINGLE FAMILY HOMEOWNERSHIP.
SIMPLY BY THE WAY THEY ARE- THEY
THEY ARE ROLLED OUT. CURRENTLY
BOTH THE INFILL INFRASTRUCTURE
GRANT PROGRAM AND THE AFFORDABLE
HOUSING AND SUSTAINABLE
COMMUNITIES PROGRAM ARE
ESSENTIALLY NOT ACCESSIBLE FOR
MOST HOMEOWNERSHIP PROGRAMS
BECAUSE OF MINIMUM DENSITY
REQUIREMENTS BUT WHILE WE
UNDERSTAND THE IMPORTANCE OF
DENSITY WE OURSELVES HAVE. BEEN
ACTIVE- PARTICIPANTS IN IN
UTILIZING DENSITY BONUSES AND
ALL OF OUR SINGLE FAMILY
SUBDIVISION- IT IT IT SHOULD NOT
PRECLUDE HOMEOWNERSHIP ARE
PROJECTS FOR BIG TWENTY. ALSO
JUST DON'T WORK TELL HFA USED TO
PROVIDE PREFERRED MORTGAGE
FINANCING FOR OUR SELF HELP HOME
BUILDERS IN AREAS THAT WE'RE
USDA FUNDING IS NOT AVAILABLE
BECAUSE OF ELIGIBILITY. IF THEY
DID THROUGH GREAT FORWARD-
FORWARD COMMITMENT PROGRAS THAT
REDUCE THE AMOUNT OF
VULNERABILITY DURING THE COURSE
OF CONSTRUCTION FOR HOME
BUILDERS. THEY NEED TO DO THIS
PROGRAM AGAIN IT HAS NOT BEEN
AROUND FOR AT LEAST. TWELVE
YEARS. SINCE THE RECESSION.
TELOGEN PHASE ALSO MANAGED A
GREAT PROGRAM IT WAS THE SCHOOL
FEES REIMBURSEMENT PROGRAM- WHEN
THEY GOT FUNDING THROUGH SOME
EARLIER BOND ISSUE- ISSUES TO-
TO OFFSET THE COSTS THAT HELP
THOUSANDS OF FIRST TIME HOME
BUYERS. WHICH ALSO NEEDS TO BE
FUNDED AGAIN THE IRONY IS THAT
THE POOREST RURAL COMMUNITIES
ARE OFTEN AREAS WITH THE HIGHEST
SCHOOL IMPACT FEES. WHICH
BECOMES A MISMATCH FOR LOCAL
HOME VALUES. MY ORGANIZATION
DOES IT SHARE OF RENTAL HOUSING
DEVELOPMENT AS WELL FOR LOW
INCOME AND ON HOUSE RESIDENTS.
SO WE KNOW THE IMPORTANCE OF
THOSE PROGRAMS BUT AFFORDABLE
HOME OWNERSHIP NEEDS TO BE A
CRITICAL PART OF OUR HOUSING
DELIVERY SYSTEM AS WELL. IN
ORDER FOR US. BOB I WOULD ALSO
JUST ANSWER ONE OF THE QUESTIONS
THAT WAS ASKED RECENTLY WE DO
SEE PEOPLE. LOW INCOME HOPE
PERSPECTIVE HOME BUYERS LOSE OUT
TO ALL CASH OFFERS WE SEE IT ALL
THE TIME- ANDERS WE HAVE FUNDS
THAT WE PREPARE FAMILIES TO
PURCHASE HOMES. WITH THE HOMES
ARE JUST NOT AVAILABLE BECAUSE
OF THE CURRENT MARKET SO I DID
WANT TO MENTION THAT. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR YOUR TIME. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR TESTIMONY
AND FOR EVERYONE ON THE PANEL
I'LL BRING IT BACK HERE TO MY
COLLEAGUES ON ANY QUESTIONS FOR
ANYONE THE PANEL MR COLOR. YOU
HAD A QUESTION OKAY. OKAY YES
QUIZZICAL INDEED MISS CLARK
SILVA. SORRY TO BE THE QUESTION
ASKER HERE TODAY BUT I AM- I
HAVE ONE ACTUALLY FOR ON THE
IMPACT FEES WHAT YOU JUST SAID
THE POOREST AREAS OFTEN HAVE CAN
HAVE THE HIGHEST IN P. IMPACT
FEES CAN YOU EXPECT. EXPAND YEAH
I WAS I WAS YOU CANNOT. I WAS
SPECIFICALLY REFERRING TO US
SCHOOL IMPACT FEES AND THE WAY
THIS THE STATE PROGRAM OPERATES
IS THAT. COMMUNITIES THAT HAVE
NOT PASSED AND CANNOT PASS LOCAL
BOND MEASURES TEND TO HAVE. THEY
ALLOW THE SCHOOL DISTRICTS TO
IMPOSE HIGHER IMPACT FEES. FOR
SCHOOLS AND THAT THERE WAS A
GREAT PROGRAM THAT KELLY TO PAY
RAN THAT- COULD OFFSET THOSE
COSTS BECAUSE WE SEE HIGHER
SCHOOL IMPACT FEES IN RURAL
AREAS. IN ABOUT. THANK YOU
MISTER COOPER IMPACT FEES ARE
HUGE I CAME FROM A LOCAL CITY
APPEAL GRILL I WAS R. FIFTEEN
YEARS THE COUNCIL AND KNEW MY
COLLEAGUES WHILE LOCAL CITY
COUNCILS IN THE IMPACT FEES ARE
A BIG SCHOOLS SEWER SO STORM
DRAIN PARKS I MEAN YOU'RE
TALKING THREE THOUSAND DOLLARS
IN FEES AND SOME THESE ISSUES.
WHAT WE ALSO SAW WERE A LOT OF
SEQUEL LAWSUIT AGAINST WORK- AND
THAT REALLY HURT I MEAN IT
REALLY DROVE DOWN AND-
DISCOURAGE BILLS IN COMING IN
THEIR BUILDING- CAN SOMEONE
COMING ON THE NEED FOR SEEK
REFORM IS PART OF THE SOLUTION
TO INCREASE HEALTH AND SUPPLY
LOWER THE COST OF HOUSING
PRODUCTION. SOMEBODY ANYBODY BE
WILLING TO STEP IN- SEQUEL IS-
IT'LL ORIGINALLY WELL
INTENTIONED LAW THAT WAS HAS
REASONS TO YOU EXIST TO PROTECT
THE ENVIRONMENT AND BLEEDING. WE
SPEND A TON OF MONEY ON A SEQUIN
HOUSES AND YARDS WHEN WE DO
PROJECTS THEY HAVE TO BE VERY
TIGHT BUT NOT TO GET PASSED THE
SCRUTINY THE REVIEW AND APPROVAL
PROCESS. BUT ANYONE CAN FILE A
LAWSUIT AGAINST SUPER APPROVAL
ANYONE FOR ANY REASON WHATSOEVER
AND. MOST OF THOSE LAWSUITS ARE
FILED BY. IT WAS JUST A QUESTION
PARTY'S WITH QUESTIONS MOTIVES
THEY'RE NOT REALLY TYPICALLY
FROM NEIGHBORS WHO ARE OPPOSED
TO PROJECT THEIR FILE BY PEOPLE
THAT YOU HAVE. OTHER MOTIVES
FRANKLY AND SO. BASICALLY THESE
LAWSUITS YOU GET WORKED OUT AND
SETTLED. IT COSTS MONEY TO DO
THAT IN THE LOW EIGHTIES THE
AVAILABILITY OF THE DELAYS THE
OPPORTUNITY TO BRING THAT SUPPLY
THE MARKET SO WHEN YOU RESTRICT
SUPPLY IN ANY FASHION YOU'RE
GOING TO REDUCE THE BELL
BUILDING HOUSES AN INCREASE THE
PRICE BECAUSE THERE'S DEMAND AND
YOU CAN'T MEET THE DEMAND
WITHOUT SUPPLY. SO THERE'S A LOT
OF NEED FOR SIMPLE REFORM I
THINK YOU'RE ALL AWARE OF THOSE
ISSUES. SOONER OR LATER WE'RE
GOING TO HAVE TO ADDRESS THEM
WE'RE NOT GONNA SOLVE THIS
PROBLEM. YES IT OBVIOUSLY WE
HAVE SEVERAL BILLS PENDING A
LEGISLATURE EXPANSE THE QUOTE.
AND WE'VE HAD BILLS WERE FOLKS
SOONER SEQUEL THAT DIDN'T LIVE
IN THE CITY. OF THE RICH THE
AFFECTED RESIDENTS I MEAN
SOMEONE THAT CAME FROM HOUSE OF
THE CITY IN THE SUIT. AND THAT'S
THE STARTING SO SEQUELS AND
POURED TOOL BUT. IT HAS BEEN
RIPE FOR ABUSE THANK YOU. I HAVE
A UP QUESTION I THINK YOU
ANSWERED IT ASSEMBLY. COOPER BUT
IN FACT IS THAT THE CASE WHICH I
BELIEVE IS THAT ANYBODY CAN
FILE- LAWSUIT UNDER SYKORA. THAT
LIVES IN ANY PART OF THE STATE
IN IT THEY DON'T HAVE TO LIVE IN
THAT JURISDICTION IS THAT TRUE.
ANYBODY. I'M NOT A SUPER TURNING
BUT I BELIEVE THAT IS TRUE IN
FACT AND THEY CAN BE FUNDED BY
PEOPLE WHO DON'T EVEN LOOK AT
THE STATE. RIGHT SO I'M GONNA
CONTINUE NOT WHAT THE QUESTION
BUT JUST A FEW COMMENTS- MMHM
PLEASE INDULGE ME BUT YOU KNOW
WE TRAVELED UP AND DOWN THE
STATE DURING THE RECESS AS
HOUSING- PARTIES OR INDIVIDUALS
THAT WERE LOOKING FOR SOLUTIONS
TO THIS HOUSING CRISIS WE GOT A
LOT OF GOOD INFORMATION- BUT AS
- MISTER SCHROEDER JUST MENTION
. YOU KNOW WE CAN DO MANY MANY
THINGS AND WE ARE DOING THAT BUT
NONE OF IT'S GOING TO SOLVE THIS
HOUSING CRISIS IF WE CONTINUE
NOT ONLY WITH SEEK WERE-
LAWSUITS BUT CANCELS LOCAL
COUNCILS AND JURISDICTIONS THAT
KEEPS SAYING NO. AND WHAT WE DO
AT THE STATE AND END UP IN MAN'S
ESSENCE BECOMES A BANDAID TO
TRYING TO FIX WHAT WE'RE NOT
DOING THAT THE LOCAL
JURISDICTION AND MANY MANYTIMES
AND I DON'T CARE WHERE YOU LIVE
I REPRESENT NORTH ORANGE COUNTY.
WE WILL HEAR- DON'T MANDATE
DON'T TELL US WHAT TO DO. STAY
IN YOUR LANE THINGS LIKE THIS
BUT THEN THE RESPONSE BACK IS IF
WE HAVE COUNCILS THAT GO THROUGH
THE PROCESS THE PROJECT COMES TO
THE PLANNING COMMISSION. GOES
THROUGH THOSE PROCESSES APPROVED
GET STATE COUNCIL. AND THEN THAT
COUNCIL BECAUSE TWO HUNDRED
PEOPLE SHOW UP SAYING NO WE
DON'T WANT THIS IN OUR BACKYARD
NIMBYS THEY TABLE IT PUSH IT
BACK SEND IT BACK TO THE
PLANNING COMMISSION WE ARE
BASICALLY PUTTING OFF AND ELAINE
AND WHAT WE ARE IN FACT DOING.
IS PUSHING A PROJECTS SOMETIMES
TWO YEARS BACK. AND THIS IS IN
FACT ONE OF THE NUMBER ONE
PROBLEMS WE HAVE SO WE CAN SAY
WELL IT'S SB NINE THAT'S TOO
MUCH FOR THIS BUT WE ARE NOT
SAYING YES. WE'RE NOT SAYING YES
TO HOUSING AND THEN THE WHOLE
OTHER IN PART IN THIS BECAUSE I
TOOK AROUND OKAY A AND SOME OF
YOU HAVE HEARD THIS IS MY- PHONE
GOING TO GO OUT IT. I TOOK A
WALK AROUND THE CAPITAL THIS
MORNING I COUNTED. ABOUT FIFTEEN
TENS IT WAS SEVEN O'CLOCK IN THE
MORNING. PEOPLE ARE GETTING UP
STARTING THEIR DAY AND WHAT DO
PEOPLE DO WHEN THEY GET UP IN
THE MORNING WHAT'S THE FIRST
THING YOU DO. SORRY GUYS WE
DON'T WANT TO TALK ABOUT IT BUT
YOU GO TO THE BATHROOM. AND IF
WE HAVE PEOPLE THOUSANDS OF
PEOPLE ACROSS THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA LIVING ON THE STREETS
WITH NO PUBLIC BATHROOMS. WHERE
ARE THEY GOING. SO THAT'S THE
SANITATION ISSUE BUT THE POINT
IS IT'S GOOD WE DON'T HAVE
HOUSING AND WE'RE NOT SAYING
YES. AND THE STATE US HERE IN
THIS ROOM GET A LOT OF FLAK FOR
SAYING WE'RE GOING TO MOVE
FORWARD. BUT THE TRUTH IS OUR
JOB IS REALLY TO STAY IN OUR
LANE BUT IF LOCALS ARE GOING TO
DO THEIR JOB. WE HAVE TO STEP IN
I'M SORRY. WE HAVE TO SAY YES TO
HOUSING AND WE HAVE TO BE ABLE
TO GIVE PEOPLE THE OPPORTUNITY.
TO BE ABLE TO LIVE IN HOMES THAT
ARE AFFORDABLE. SO ALL WE CAN DO
IS LISTEN TAKE THE ADVICE HERE
TRY TO PUT FORWARD BILLS BUT I
ASK OUR COLLEAGUES AND THOSE OF
YOU OUT THERE LISTENING DO NO
HARM. THANK YOU MISS CLARK SILVA
SHARE YOUR COMMENTS. I'D HAVE TO
SAY I AGREE YES TO HOUSING.
MISTER SERRA. OKAY SO WE'RE
GONNA WE GOT INTO THAT
DISCUSSION WE'RE GONNA HAVE A
LITTLE DIFFERENT PERSPECTIVE
FROM THE LOCAL LEVEL- LOCAL
AGENCIES HAVE NO PROBLEMS HAVE
APPROVING HOUSING WHAT THEY HAVE
PROBLEMS WITH. IS WHEN THEY ARE
HANDED A BAG OF REGULATIONS THAT
CAN TAKE UP TO TEN YEARS FOR
STUDIES AND EVERYTHING ELSE TO
GET THROUGH A PROCESS. AND THEY
HAVE LIMITED STAFF TO BE ABLE TO
DO IT- THAT STUFF COMES FROM US-AND THAT'S WHAT THEY'RE TALKING
ABOUT WHEN THEY SAY HEY YOU KNOW
WHAT. ENOUGH MANDATES ALREADY.
BECAUSE THOSE ARE THE THINGS
THAT. WHEN YOU DO A STUDY THAT
TAKES THREE YEARS. AND THEN THE
OTHER STUDIES WITH THAT YOU DID
EARLIER ON BECOME OBSOLETE. ALL
THOSE CITIES ARE DOING IS TRYING
TO KEEP UP WITH THE REGULATIONS
AND BEING ABLE TO GET A PROJECT
THROUGH WITHOUT IT BEING
CHALLENGED BY SEQUEL AT THE END
OF THE DAY BECAUSE THAT'S WHAT
THAT'S WHAT THE BIG HOLD UP IS.
OF A LOT OF CITIES OUR MASTER
PLAN CITIES THEY WENT THROUGH A
PROCESS BECAUSE AS WE ARE
TALKING BUT WE HAVE GROWTH RINGS
AND EACH EACH RAIN LEARNED FROM
THE LAST RAIN WHAT WORKS AND
WHAT DOESN'T AND HOW YOU LAY OUT
A CITY. AND THOSE THOSE
APPROVALS GO THROUGH EIGHT CD
YOU CAN'T GET AN APPROVAL FOR
YOUR HOUSING ELEMENT IF YOU
DON'T HAVE CERTAIN ELEMENTS IN
IT. BUT YOU CAN'T CITIES DON'T
BUILD HOMES. BUILDERS BUILD
HOMES. AND THE ONLY WAY THEY CAN
BUILD IS IF THEY HOUSING. IS IF
THEY'RE OUT DO YOU GUYS WANT ME
TO STOP. OKAY BUT IT DID LOOK
LIKE WE DID. SO IT'S THERE'S A
COMBINATION OF PROBLEMS HERE BUT
THE OTHER THING WE HAVE TO KEEP
UNDER CONSIDERATION. IS AS WE GO
OUT AND ALLOW HOUSING INTO THOSE
GROWTH RANGE WHICH WE NEED TO
DESPERATELY. WE ALSO HAVE TO
HAVE A BUSINESS ENVIRONMENT THAT
ENCOURAGES JOBS IN THOSE AREAS.
BECAUSE OTHERWISE ALL THOSE
PEOPLE CAN BE DRIVING. ALL THOSE
PEOPLE HAVE 61% OF THE AREA
PEOPLE IN MY REGION. COMMUTE TWO
HOURS TO GO GET A JOB ATTEMPT TO
WORK. THAT'S NOT GOOD FOR THE
ENVIRONMENT. SO WE KEEP WORKING
AGAINST OURSELVES BECAUSE WE
LIMIT LIMIT ARE JOB CREATION. WE
HAVE MORE ENVIRONMENT WITH VAMP
BAYERN MENTAL RESTRICTIONS AND
THERE WE WANT MORE HOUSING WHICH
WE NEED DESPERATELY. AND YET WE
PILE A BUNCH OF RESTRICTIONS ON
THAT VERY HOUSING FOR THE CITY'S
TO BE THE REFEREE AND THEN WE
BLAME THE CITIES BECAUSE THEY'RE
NOT DOING WHAT WE THINK THEY
SHOULD BE DOING. THEY'RE TRYING
THEY REALLY ARE AND IF YOU WANT
TO COME DOWN TO MY REGIONAL GIVE
YOU A GOOD TOUR THE CITY IS
GOING TO BUILD HOUSING BUT THEY
DO HAVE AN APPROVAL AND THEY
HAVE THREE VOTES OUT OF FIVE TO
SAY YES AND MANY OF THEM DON'T
TAKE THAT AND WE HAVE THAT CAN
WIN THE WORLD DOING A REMODELING
WE HAVE A CHOICE. CHECK FOR
TWENTY YEARS WE'RE ALSO IN A
REMOTE WORKING ENVIRONMENT WHERE
MORE AND MORE PEOPLE CAN WORK
FROM HOME SO WE GOT TO HAVE IT
AS WELL. I DON'T FEEL SORRY FOR
LOW COLLECTORS WHO WON'T DO
THEIR JOBS SORRY CAN WE JUST-
BRING IT BACK HERE TO SEE IF
THERE'S ANY OTHER QUESTIONS FOR
THE- COMMITTEE OR THE THAT THE-
FOLKS WERE TESTIFYING. ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS. MISTER KALRA. BUT I
YOU KNOW I. THINK THAT I JUST.
R. S. TO CHIME IN AND SOME OF
OUR COLLEAGUE FROM. ORANGE
COUNTY I SERVED ON THE CITY
COUNCIL OF A MAJOR CITY FOR
EIGHT YEARS WHEN WE WERE THE
ONLY ONES BUILDING ALL THE TOWNS
AROUND US AND NOTHING TO DO WITH
. WHAT WITH BARACK RECEIVE A
REGULATION OR ANYTHING THE
REALITY IS THAT THEY JUST DON'T
WANNA BUILD. I WAS ON A ON A BAG
. NOW THEY WERE GIVEN A- GIVEN A
ON HOUSING ALL THE SMALL TOWNS
GET OUT SO THEY DIDN'T CARE.
BECAUSE THERE IS NO
ACCOUNTABILITY- THE JOBS ARE
BEING CREATED APPLE
HEADQUARTERS. ONE OF THE MOST
SIGNIFICANT- AND INDUSTRIAL
OFFICE COMPLEXES BUILT IN THE
LAST. TWO DECADES. AND THAT SAME
CITY BLOCK ANY OFFICER HOUSING
UNTIL SB THIRTY FIVE WAS PASSED
AND WE FINALLY HAD A CHANCE. TO
BUILD HOUSES HOUSING DOWN THE
STREET WITH APPLE HEADQUARTERS
SO- THERE THERE'S- MATH. THAT
GETS REPEATED THAT THE STATE IS.
YOUR MEDDLING AT A LOCAL LEVEL
THE REALITIES OF THE LOCAL LEVEL
THEY'VE ABDICATED THE
RESPONSIBILITY. STATES FAR TOO
MANY OF THE SMALL TOWNS. AND
SMALL CITIES DO NOT WANT TO
BUILD. AND I'VE SEEN IT YOUR
WITH SILICON VALLEY IS THE
ECONOMIC ENGINE OF NOT JUST THE
STATE BUT THE COUNTRY. SO JOBS
ARE THERE GREAT JOBS ARE THERE
PEOPLE HAVE MONEY. THE PROBLEM
IS THAT THERE ARE ENOUGH HOMES
PEOPLE TO BUY. THAT IS BECAUSE
THE SMALL SMALLER TOWNS IN
JURISDICTIONS THINK IT'S JUST
THE RESPONSIBILITY. OF SAN
FRANCISCO THOUSAND OPEN TO BUILD
AND NOBODY ELSE'S. IT DOESN'T
WORK THAT WAY EVERYONE HAS TO
TAKE RESPONSIBILITY. AND WE MADE
IT AS EASY AS POSSIBLE IN TERMS
OF FACILITATING- THE HIGHER
DENSITY FACILITATING TRANSIT
ORIENTED DEVELOPMENT. THEY STILL
DON'T WANT ANY BETTER THAN THE
DAY- THEY DON'T WANT TO BE TOLD
WHAT TO DO BUT THEY'RE NOT
TAKING ON THE RESPONSIBILITY. OF
DEALING WITH THESE WE ISSUE. AND
THAT'S WHAT. I'VE SEEN OVER THE
LAST. NO FOURTEEN PLAY YEARS OF
BEING ALLOWED OFFICIALS LOOK
ABOUT. IT GETS WORSE AND WORSE
WELL THESE BIG CITIES. THEIR
BEST TO DO WITH THE HOMELESSNESS
IS. NUMBER RAPPER WE- SUPPORT OF
. AND TO BUILD NEW MARKET RATE
AND AFFORDABLE HOUSING. TRY TO
DO ALL THAT. AT THE SAME TIME
WHILE. BEING SUED BY NEIGHBORING
JURISDICTIONS WHEN YOU KNOW WHEN
THEY'RE ACTUALLY TRYING TO BUILD
NEAR THE BORDER- IT WITHIN THE
CITY LIMITS BECAUSE THE
NEIGHBORING JURISDICTIONS ANYONE
HOUSING. CLOSE TO THEM LET ALONE
IN THEIR OWN JURISDICTION.
THAT'S WHAT I'VE WITNESSED DAY
IN DAY OUT FOR WELL OVER A
DECADE AND I THINK THAT THAT'S
WHY. WE HAVE THESE DEBATES ON ON
WHAT. IF ANYTHING FACT
SACRAMENTO SHOULD DO. TO PUSH
THE ISSUE. IN SAN JOSE THANK YOU
MR CALLER. MISTER COOPER BUT
LOOKING FOR MEDIUM SIZE CITY IT
IS THE GOVERNMENT THAT DOESN'T
STATE GOVERNMENT YES SOME
CITIES. SHOULD RESPONSIBILITIES
BUT AS REASON FOLKS MOVING OUT
OF THE BAY AREA MOVING SEGMENT
DRIVING PRICES UP. YOUR PRICES
ARE EXORBITANT THERE FOR
WHATEVER REASON APPLE OR FLICKR
COMING IN. PEOPLE CAN AFFORD TO
LIVE THERE IS STILL COME DOWN AT
THE FORCIBLE. BOTH MY KIDS HAVE
HOUSES THEY MOVED HOME FOR TWO
YEARS AFTER COLLEGE TO SAVE
MONEY TO BUY HEALTHCARE DOLLARS
BUT HOUSE IN APRIL OF LAST YEAR.
AND PAY FIFTY THOUSAND DOLLARS
OVER. ASKING PRICE TO GET A
HOUSE. WE WILL BUILD CALIFORNIA
NOT BIZ THE HOUSE. DEVELOPERS
DIFFICULT WHEN LAWS ARE. THE MAN
. SOLAR THE AND THAT. AND ADDS
TO THE- I'VE BEEN FIFTEEN A
LOCAL. AND IT THAT'S CRAZY.
CALIFORNIA'S LAW EXPENSIVE. YOU
AT ALL. THE HIGHEST PRICES GAS.
FOOD PRICES IN JUST IMPACTS THE
COMPOUNDS IT MORE TIME AND TIME
AGAIN WE GOTTA DO SOMETHING WE
CAN'T BUILD OUR WAY OUT OF THIS.
AFFORDABLE HOUSING YOUR BILL TO
HEAR HALF MOON DOOR TO DOOR.
OPERATION HOKEY RUKI HALF
MILLION DOLLARS IN SACRAMENTO TO
REHAB HOTEL IN DOWNTOWN
SACRAMENTO WHAT CAN YOU BILL FOR
THAT. SO I MEAN IT IS A PROBLEM
I DON'T SEE IS GETTING OUT OF IT
ANYTIME SOON IT'S BEEN
EXACERBATED IT WAS IT. TOOK IT
WAS CURRENT LONG BEFORE WE CAME
HERE. AND BEFORE WE LEAVE IS NOT
ON THE SALT SO IT IS VERY
FRUSTRATING I KNOW WE ALL HAVE
GREAT WE'RE VERY PASSIONATE
ABOUT IT. AND WE HAVE GOOD
INTENTIONS BUT- THIS LIKE I SAID
WE'RE NOT GOING TO OUR WAY OUT
OF THIS IT IS IT IS INSANE WHAT
IS GOING ON RIGHT NOW AND FOR
SOME FOLKS IF THE SEPARABLE. FOR
FOLKS TO BE HOMELESS NOT ANYBODY
HERE BUT FROM OTHER FOLKS SO I
HEAR MY COLLEAGUES ARE YOUR
THING AND I AGREE WITH YOU A LOT
OF ASPECTS OF IT BUT- THERE ARE
A LOT OF MOVING PARTS TO THIS.
THANK YOU MISTER COOPER ANY
OTHER QUESTIONS COMMENTS- MR
CALLER JUST AS ONE QUICK YOU
KNOW THE REALITY IS ALL SAME
BUILDERS AND DEVELOPERS. THAT
FOCUSING HAVING TROUBLE
BUILDING. CITY COUNCILS ASKING
IF THEY CAN GET PERMITTED TO
BUILD ARE BEING DENIED LEFT AND
RIGHT. AND THAT'S WHAT I'M
REFERRING THOSE SMALL AT THOSE
SMALLER TOWNS OF SILICON VALLEY
BUT ACTUALLY ALLOWED BUILDING TO
BE LESS A MOTIVATION FOR FOLKS
TO COME INTO THE SACRAMENTO AREA
INTO THE CENTRAL VALLEY BECAUSE
OUR BE MORE HOUSING STOCK
AVAILABLE TO THEM. IN THEIR OWN
BACKYARD YEP. JERRY HAVE LAWS
THAT ARE SPECIFIC THAT SILICON
VALLEY AND NOT AS NECESSARY I.
DON'T WANT. NOTE ON THAT. LITTLE
BIT- TO CALL- AS WE DO OUR-
PLACE. DID YOU HAVE AN
ADDITIONAL COMMENT TO OPEN A AND
BE RECOGNIZED. SURE THANK YOU.
SO WHY OF THE ISSUE IS YOU THE
LIVE TO IT SAN INSULA VALLEY IS
NOT WHAT'S GOING ON DOWN AND SO
AND SOUTHWEST RIVERSIDE COUNTY.
AND SO YOU CAN'T APPLY SOLUTIONS
FOR SILICON VALLEY THAT WORK
DOWN THERE BECAUSE YOU'LL YOU
WHAT YOU'LL DO IS YOU'LL SET UP
A WHOLE DIFFERENT- IT SHOULD
HAVE A WHOLE ARRAY OF DIFFERENT
PROBLEMS. INCLUDING
TRANSPORTATION ISSUES WE DON'T
HAVE THE FUNDING THAT THEY HAVE
UP HERE FOR ROADSAND BRIDGES
AND IF THEY DON'T WANT TO BUILD
MORE ROADS BUT WE DESPERATELY
NEED MORE ROADS IF WE'RE GOING
TO HAVE MORE HOUSING. AND WE
DESPERATELY NEED MORE JOBS AND
WE'RE WE'RE DISCOURAGING ALL OF
IT. SO THAT'S WHAT THAT'S WHAT
THE CROSS THIS ARGUMENT IS
THERE'S DIFFERENT PLACES HAVE
DIFFERENT ISSUES AND WE NEED TO
TREAT THEM DIFFERENTLY WE CAN'T
JUST LAY A BLANKET OVER THE
WHOLE THING. THANK YOU THANK YOU
RESIDE OUT AT CHAIR CREO. THANK
YOU I LOVE THE ROBUST DIALOGUE
AND CONVERSATION I THINK IT IS
IMPORTANT AND CRITICAL AND PART
OF A LARGER COMPLICATED ISSUE
RELATED TO EVERYTHING HOUSING
HOMELESSNESS TRANSPORTATION GOOD
JOBS. EQUITABLE RESOURCES IT'S
ALL RELATED. AND THE TOPIC OF
OUR CONVERSATION TODAY IT'S
ULTIMATELY HOMEOWNERSHIP WHICH
HAS BECOME LESS AND LESS
ATTAINABLE ALL OF US I CAN'T
AFFORD TO BUY A HOME IN THE
COMMUNITY THAT I REPRESENT. A
TWO BEDROOM SMALL CALIFORNIA
BUNGALOW IN THE COMMUNITY OF EL
SERENO WHICH A FEW YEARS AGO YOU
COULD GET FOR UNDER THREE
HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLARS JUST
SOLD LAST MONTH FOR ONE POINT
TWO MILLION DOLLARS. THERE'S
ABSOLUTELY NO WAY THAT THE
COMMUNITY THAT I REPRESENT IS
ABLE TO AFFORD THAT HOME AT THE
CRUX OF ALL THIS AND AS WE HAVE
PANELIST. HERE IT IT REALLY IS
ABOUT HOW WE ARE MAKING. HOME
OWNERSHIP MORE ATTAINABLE TO
EVERYDAY PEOPLE ACROSS OUR STATE
AND- ARE WE CREATING THE
SOLUTIONS FOR IT SO AS WE
EVALUATE THESE BARRIERS AT THE
STATE LEVEL AND LOOK. TOWARDS
MAKING FUNDING DECISIONS FOR THE
FUTURE. SHOULD STATE FUNDING
FOCUS ON CREATING MORE SUPPLY OF
OWNERSHIP AND IF SO AT WHAT
LEVELS. AND HOW FAST DOES IT
TAKE TO BUILD. IF ANYONE IN THE
PANEL CAN ANSWER THOSE QUESTIONS
WE'D BE MOST APPRECIATIVE. THANK
YOU I'LL JUMP IN QUICKLY ON THE
FIRST- SHOULD CALIFORNIA INVEST
IN THE ANSWER IS YES- AS I WAS
TRYING MY BEST TO ILLUSTRATE THE
INVESTMENT IN HOMEOWNERSHIP IS.
TINY TO NONEXISTENT SO WE NEED
TO INCREASE THE SUPPLY AND THAT
WILL MAKE AN ENORMOUS DIFFERENCE
IN BALANCING. THE
UNAFFORDABILITY. I THINK I'VE I
WOULD SECOND THAT AND- ALSO SAY
THAT. IF THE STATE COULD
ACCELERATE ITS- FUNDING AWARD
PROCESS AND CON CAN. EXTRACTION
OIL- OUT ARRANGEMENTS THAT THEY
HAVE WITH AWARD EASE IT WOULD BE
QUITE HELPFUL BECAUSE TYPICALLY
WHEN WE APPLY WE ARE READY TO
BUILD AND- SO WE CAN WE CAN
START. YOU KNOW WITHIN A MONTH
OF WHEN WE APPLY. ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS FOR THE PANEL BEFORE
MOVE TO CUT PUBLIC COMMENT. THIS
IS- YOU'RE GONNA ADD ON YEAH
THAT SAME ITEM OF CLEARLY THERE
ARE FINANCING PROGRAMS HERE THAT
ARE VERY BENEFICIAL AND WELL
DESIGNED IT NEEDS SUPPORT. IF
YOU DON'T INCREASE SUPPLY. JUST
POURING MORE MONEY INTO THE SAME
SIZE BAG SO NO MATTER WHERE THE
MONEY COMES FROM IF YOU'RE
PUTTING MORE MONEY INTO THE
MARKET WITHOUT INCREASING
SUPPLY. INCREASING PRICE YOU'RE
PUTTING MORE BUYERS INTO THE
POOL OF THE SAME HOUSES SO
SUPPLY IS KEY IT'S BASIC
ECONOMICS WE DON'T HAVE MORE
SUPPLY WILL NOT RESOLVE THE
PROBLEM. THEY YOU VERY MUCH IS A
PRE THE- CONVERSATION HERE ON
THE DICE AND WITH THE PANELISTS
TODAY- YOU KNOW I WANT TO AGREE
WITH SOME OF THE COMMENTS MY
COLLEAGUES MENTIONED I THINK ALL
OF US AGREE WE NEED TO BUILD
MORE HOMES. FOR THREE POINT FIVE
MILLION HOMES SCHEIBER WE NEED
TO BE IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
ALL HOMES AT ALL INCOME LEVELS
VERY LOW INCOME- A YOU KNOW
MIDDLE INCOME MARKET RATE AND
ALL OF THE ABOVE STRATEGY I
THINK IS CRITICAL THAT'S WHY
THINGS LIKE SB THIRTY FIVE SB
FIFTY S. B. NINE. AND SOME OF
THE STREAMLINING BILLS ARE SO
CRITICAL TO ENSURE THAT WE HAVE
THE ABILITY TO DO THAT AND THAT
OUR COMMUNITIES ARE DOING WHAT
THEY NEED TO DO- I GET
APPRECIATE. THE CONVERSATION WE
WILL NOW I'LL TURN IT BACK OVER
TO MY CO CHAIR AND CHAIR CARILLO
FOR THE PUBLIC COMMENT PORTION
OF THE PRESENTATION TODAY. THANK
YOU MEDICAL CARE AND AGAIN THANK
YOU TO ALL THE MEMBERS THAT
PARTICIPATED IN TODAY'S
CONVERSATION CLEARLY. IN THE
LAST FEW HEARINGS THAT WE HAVE
HAD BOTH ENDS OF FOREIGN AND
JOINTLY WITH HOUSING. SEVERAL
DIFFERENT ISSUES HAVE COME TO
THE LIGHT TRANSPORTATION HOUSING
HOMELESSNESS MENTAL HEALTH WHICH
IS A WHOLE OTHER SUB COMMITTEE
AS WELL AND RESOURCES TO. ON
WRAPAROUND SERVICES WHICH ARE
COLLEAGUES HAVE ALSO MENTIONED
AND SO. I THINK WE ARE FEELING
THE FRUSTRATION FELT ACROSS THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA WHEN IT
COMES TO WHAT WE'RE SEEN AND
WHAT PEOPLE ARE EXPERIENCING SO.
THE GOOD THING IS THAT WE'RE
HAVING THE CONVERSATIONS
NECESSARY THAT HOPEFULLY MOVE
THE NEEDLE FORWARD WE ARE NOW
ACCEPTING PUBLIC COMMENT- THE
NUMBER TO CALL IN ITS EIGHT
SEVEN SEVEN SIX NINE TWO EIGHT
NINE FIVE SEVEN. THE PUBLIC
ACCESS CODE IS ONE THREE ONE
FIVE FOUR FOUR FOUR OPERATOR DO
WE HAVE ANY CALLERS. IF YOU WISH
TO PROVIDE PUBLIC COMMENT TODAY
OVER THE PHONE PLEASE PRESS ONE
SEVEN ZERO. THAT COMMAND AGAIN.
ONE NINE ZERO. AND ONE MOMENT
PLEASE WHILE WHILE WE PROVIDE
THEM WITH LINE NUMBERS. ONE MORE
MOMENT PLEASE. PRETTY MUCH THE
CARD. FOR AND OUR FIRST COMMENT
COMES FROM LINE FOURTEEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. THANK YOU HONORABLE
CHAIRS CARDIO ANALYTICS FOR THIS
IMPORTANT EQUITY FOCUSED HEARING
MY NAME IS AMY HINES STRIKE WITH
WILDCAT CONSULTING REPRESENTING
THE CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY LAND
TRUST NETWORK WE INCLUDE OVER
TWENTY SEVEN FEEL TS ELIOT
THROUGHOUT THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. EACH OF YOU HAVE
VERY PROMINENT COMMUNITY LAND
TRUST IN YOUR DISTRICT. HAVE
YOUR HAS POPPED OUT THAT LAY
FONG OTHERS FEEL USE AND SHARE
WITH THE NORTHERN CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY LAND TRUST AMONG
OTHERS THE LP'S THE COMMUNITY
LAND TRUST MODEL CREATES
OPPORTUNITIES FOR LOW INCOME
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR TO STAVE
OFF DISPLACEMENT THROUGH
ACQUIRING AND REHABILITATING
PROPERTIES AND KEEPING RESIDENTS
IN PLACE. OR DEVELOPING
PROPERTIES FROM THE GROUND UP
CONSTRUCTION THE LAND IS
STEWARDED BY THE CLP AND
PERPETUAL AFFORDABILITY THROUGH
A RENEWABLE NINETY NINE YEAR
GROUND LEASE AND THE BUILDING
STRUCTURE CAN BE SOLD TO THE
RESIDENTS WHICH IS TERRIBLE AND
THEREFORE BUILD
INTERGENERATIONAL WEALTH. AS A
COMPONENT OF SOLVING THE HOUSING
CRISIS IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY LAND TRUST
CANNOT BE OVERLOOKED WE LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH YOUR
OFFICES TO INVEST IN THIS PROVEN
HOUSING. JUSTICE ALL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU COLOR. A LINE FOR.
THANK YOU HELLO THIS IS LAUREN
CUT THE HARD TALKING TO HAPPEN
HELPING BE WITH JENNY APPRECIATE
PAID DIALOGUE IN THE INFORMATION
I HEARING THE TYPICALLY WE WANT
TO ACKNOWLEDGE AND SECOND THE
COMMENTS MADE TODAY BY HABITAT
FOR HUMANITY AND ENCOURAGE THE
LEGISLATURE TO CONTINUE THE
CONVERSATION ON EXPLORING
APPROVAL FROM OWNERSHIP
OPPORTUNITIES. IN CALIFORNIA
THANK YOU. THANK YOU NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. FINE. SIXTEEN GOOD
AFTERNOON SHARES COMMITTEE
MEMBERS JENNIFER SPOKE ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
REALTORS THAT WE'VE DISCUSSED
GENERALLY THE ONLY WAY TO VOTE
HOMEOWNERSHIP FOR INDIVIDUAL
MOBILE BALKAN OPPORTUNITIES FOR
INDIVIDUALS WITH HER
HOMEOWNERSHIP ACCORDING THE
FEDERAL RESERVE STUDY IN TWENTY
NINETEEN- MY HOMEWORK HOMEOWNER
FINANCES REMAIN DRIVEN ALMOST
ENTIRELY BY HOMEOWNERSHIP STATUS
IN FACT THE ABILITY TO
ACCUMULATE EQUITY ON THE FULL
VALUE OF AN INVESTMENT. ONLY
INVESTING A FRACTION OF THE
MONEY UP FRONT PROVIDE THE ONLY
SIGNIFICANT OPPORTUNITY FOR
WEALTH ACCUMULATION FOR ALL OF
CALIFORNIA FAMILIES ARE THE
RESULT OF THE MEDIAN FAMILY IN%
THE U. S. HAS A WEALTH OF A
HUNDRED TWENTY ONE THOUSAND
DOLLARS IN THE US WHEN A FAMILY
ONLY HAVE ROUGHLY SIXTY THREE
HUNDRED DOLLAR NETWORK THAT
THEY'VE HAD FOR THE PAST FOUR
DECADES MEANWHILE HOMEOWNERS
HAVE REQUIRED AT LEAST TWO
HUNDRED AND FIFTY ABOUT. FIFTY
FIVE THOUSAND DOLLARS AND WHAT
THE MACHINE CAN PRINT. HERE'S A
DOUBLE HELPING. FOR KIDS READ
THE- OR CONVERSION MERCURY
HOUSING RECEIVING. A OVER
BILLION IN THE BUDGET. MEANWHILE
THIS YEAR'S BUDGET AND- A LITTLE
OVERSEE NINE MILLION DOLLARS FOR
HOME ON. PRO THAT ARE OVER BY
THE DEPARTMENT OF HOUSING AND
COMMUNITY DEVELOPMENT. BUT THE
ONLY THREE AND A HALF PERCENT OF
THE FUNDS ALLOCATED TO DETER
CRIMINAL HOUSING PROJECT-
PROGRAMS. AN ADDITIONAL ONE
HUNDRED FORTY MILLION DOLLARS OF
ALLOCATED BY COLLECTING THE DOWN
PAYMENT ASSISTANCE WHICH IS NOT
NEARLY ENOUGH TO SATISFY THE
DEMAND BY THE PUBLIC. FOR
OWNERSHIP HOUSING OPPORTUNITIES.
INCREASING VPA FUNDING IS THE
MOST EFFICIENT WAY TO INCREASE
OWNERSHIP OPPORTUNITY THROUGHOUT
CALIFORNIA. WE ARE ALONG WITH
OUR COALITION PARTNERS RECENTLY
SENT BUDGET SUBCOMMITTEE FOR-
REQUEST RESPECTFULLY REQUEST
WITH SECURE CONSIDER ALLOCATING
A SMALL BUT MEANINGFUL PORTION
OF THE- UNBUDGETED PROJECTED
SURPLUS FUNDS EQUALING ABOUT 30%
OF THE FUNDS. A LOT OUT ALLOWED
TO CATER FOR DIFFERENT HOUSING
PROGRAMS- WE'RE ASKING A MINIMUM
OF TWENTY PER OF BETTER FOUR
HUNDRED THREE NO DOLLARS A THOSE
FUN BECAUSE THE CAO HOME. AND
PERCENT OF THAT ABOUT TWO
HUNDRED AND ONE MILLION DOLLARS
TO BE BALLOT DEDICATED TO
KEEPING PROGRAMS. ALL OF THIS IS
IN AN EFFORT TO CREATE OP. FOR
MORE HOMEOWNERSHIP STATEWIDE
BOTH THESE PROGRAMS ARE DEFINED
WITHIN IMMUNE ELIGIBILITY. AND
ALLOW ADDITIONAL RESOURCES TO
CREATE OPPORTUNITY FOR FAMILIES
TO RESURGENT THIRTEEN FROM
OWNERSHIP THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
LINE A FIFTEEN. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH- MY NAME HOLD MY CONTAINER
DIRECTOR FOR ECONOMIC EQUITY
REMAINING INSTITUTE IN OAKLAND
WHERE WE WORK TIRELESSLY FOR
RACIAL AND ECONOMIC JUSTICE WE
ABSOLUTELY CANNOT TALK ABOUT
LISTEN HOMEOWNERSHIP WITHOUT
TALKING ABOUT FINANCE OF LONDON
FOR THE PAST FEW YEARS GREEN
LINING UP CONDUCTED RESEARCH ON
HOME MONDAY IN CALIFORNIA AND
FOUND THAT THE MAJORITY OF
MORTGAGE LENDERS IN THE STATE
ARE UNDER REGULATED NON BANK
LENDERS MAJORITY OF PEOPLE UNDER
REGULATED LONG. LET ALONE COME
BORROWER CONNECT. WATER CONTINUE
TO BE DIFFERENT PARTS OF THE
EXCLUDE FROM HOMEOWNERSHIP
THROUGH LAW LEVEL OF MARKET
MONDAY. MORE INFORMATION ON THIS
BE FOUND IN OUR LAKE DISTRICT
THAT IT COMING OUT. TITLE ALL
ONE IN COMMUNITY OF COLOR. I
STRONGLY HURDLES A LOOK AT THE
WOULD BE A TO SHARE YOU HAVE TO
WATCH ABOUT THAT. ALL FINANCIAL
INSTITUTIONS AND PLAYED A KERR
ROLE IN. READING THE SUCCESSFUL
HOMEOWNERS GAP THAT DOES EXACTLY
THANK YOU- BETWEEN PEOPLE COLOR
LIGHT. ARE AFTER THINGS LIKE
PUTTING OUT AN INITIAL PRODUCT
AND SERVICE. ALL LOWER BRING FOR
THINKING THE COLOR AND THE
INABILITY TO ME THE NEEDS OF OUR
- WHERE THEY ARE. IN ORDER TO
ACCESS TO HOME. OPPORTUNITIES
THERE NEEDS TO BE MORE CONCRETE
EFFORT TO ADDRESS FIRST WHAT
THROUGHOUT THE FINANCE SYSTEM.
INCLUDING INCREASE RIGHT NOW.
I'M NOT BANK MORTGAGE. AND
BETTER INVEST REQUIRE. REMINDING
IF YOU'D A FAN AFTER READING
COUPLE OF LIKE KERN ANY OF YOU
PARTICULAR I STRONGLY ENCOURAGE
YOU TO TAKE A LOOK AT OUR
HISTORY. EVERY ACT A FOLLOW UP
WHICH YOUR DIRECTLY. AND YOUR
WORKERS. BUT MUCH. AND
UNIVERSITY ONE QUARTER QUARTER
HAVE WELL IN IT AND IT WILL CUT
ON YOUR MIKE- YOU'D LOVE TO CUT
IT OFF BEFORE WENDY CARILLO
BECAUSE YOU LOVE THE CONTROLLER
AND ACCOUNTANT AND I THEN I HAVE
A CALLER THANK YOU VERY MUCH
OPERATOR NEXT CALLER. THE LINE.
TWENTY THIS IS MARCH SEVENTH OF
THE CALIFORNIA HOUSING
PARTNERSHIP AND- WELL WE VERY
MUCH SUPPORT INCREASE
HOMEOWNERSHIP INVESTMENT BY THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA AND ALSO
JUST WANT TO ADD TO THE
DISCUSSION THAT- THE CALIFORNIA
DOES ACTUALLY- PUT A LOT OF
RESOURCES INTO. OWNERSHIP NOW
IT'S JUST THAT IT DOESN'T
THROUGH THE TAX SYSTEM THE
MORTGAGE INTEREST DEDUCTION
FROM. STATE INCOME TAXES AS WELL
AS KIND OF- YEAH OF THE
DEFERRALS FOR SORT OF PROPERTY
TAXES. ARE A HUGE INVESTED BY
THE STATE IN THE BILLIONS OF
DOLLARS BUT THEY'RE JUST NOT
TARGETED AT THE LOW INCOME HOME
BY FIRST TIME HOME BUYERS WE'RE
HOPING TO ASSIST THEM SO. THERE
MIGHTBE A REAL POTENTIAL TO
REFORM HOW THE STATE SPENDS ITS
CURRENT RESOURCES RATHER THAN
HAVING TO INVEST THE SCARCE
RESOURCES THAT ARE NEEDED FOR A
VARIETY OF HOUSING NEEDS SO.
THAT YOUR CONSIDERATION OF THAT
CONCEPT THANK YOU. THANK YOU
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. WE HAVE NO
FURTHER COMMENT AT THIS TIME.
THANK YOU SO MUCH OPERATOR I'D
LIKE TO THANK OUR BUDGET STAFF
AND OUR HOUSING STAFF FOR ALL OF
THEIR DILIGENT WORK IN PUTTING
THESE THIS- INFORMATIONAL
HEARING BETWEEN SEPT FOUR AND-
HOUSING COMMITTEE WE MUCH
APPRECIATE AND THANK YOU TO ALL
THE MEMBERS THAT PARTICIPATED IN
TODAY'S VERY ROBUST AND VERY
IMPORTANT CONVERSATION. THANK
YOU. WE ARE ADJOURNED.